guys the you oh god what the fuck was that voice guys the
youtube servers are down on my side every time i can't i
can't even go to my live studio oh wait no not mine gk it's
okay now jk it's okay now jk it's fixed now okay i was
saying that because i kept getting this.
I was like, what do you mean error try again?
What do you mean?
What does that mean?
And then I kept like refreshing and everything and then it
wouldn't, um, like it wouldn't refresh.
I was so confused.
I was like, why can't I refresh?
I'm so confused.
Paid wall chat, LMG.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Thank you, Alan.
All right.
So for those who don't know, uh, for those who don't know,
um, the store at Doki Merch is finally open.
Now there's headers, guys.
Uh, we have headers now.
Like, we don't really have any new items.
Yes, we, I know a lot of the items in the store is, um, is
sold out because we're working on fulfillment at the moment.
So we can't take in, we don't want to take in new orders.
uh even though like you know uh some of the merch should be
like there forever type deal even retro doki i.e right now
present me um will uh will still be in the store after even
after retro doki is like semi-retired uh but we're working
on fulfillment so we're making sure that like orders are
going out uh we're shipping orders for now so we don't want
to take in new orders until uh until uh we're able to
fulfill majority of the orders um another update so yes
crokey voice pack our very first voice pack is out now um
you can hear listen to the preview uh you can listen to the
preview of the uh dokey merch store of what the of what it
sounds like all right i just want you to know croaky worked
very hard in that voice pack so yes check it out it's only
um it is yours for only five dollars i should put 4.99 just
to entice you guys more i was like oh my god for only 4.99
you can get your croaky voice pack uh nova thank you for the
gifted membership thank you thank you and cova thank you for
the five gifted ships thank you thank you i you guys um so
anyway i am yes uh i am not tired or i mean i'm a little bit
tired to be fair i started my workday at fucking 10 in the
morning i'm sipping my api juice right now you know like
those like um those those like paper the paper um apple
juice uh containers like as if i'm in kindergarten This is
how I feel like right now mentally
Sipping my little like the kindergarten apple juice Love
that first car Manso thank you for the super chat Thank you,
thank you Regarding like, you're like Doki, when will we
have Kroki merch?
I am currently talking with the creators At the moment of
Kroki Because like I don't know if people realized this I
talked about this in the in the 3d stream um and it was more
so it was more so of like croaky was based off of a free
crow uh model that they made and I said that like oh I saw
it on Twitter I saw this free crow model um that this
creator made and I thought it was super cute so then I was
like oh can you do one key design one for me um that's just
like me like based off me and they're like yeah they can but
because the model is sort of like free for everybody um like
the original model is free for everybody to download uh
which in talks at the moment regarding making merch off of
croaky because it is based on her original her other
original model so let's fingers crossed um like she was open
to the idea but like obviously we have to like negotiate and
stuff about like how to to do uh to use it like a
commercially, so we are currently like negotiating to see
like Like what we can do with regarding croaky and what we
can We already missed your oh she bro croaky was
Look croaky was made as it was like really made as a one-off
joke.
I Honestly, I honestly did not expect croaky to like blow up
uh Blow up in the way it did like sort of like overnight
But I'm really glad all of you guys Love croaky who not they
welcome to the tomato farm welcome welcome Croaky is my
favorite The dokey verse which is your favorite dokey guys
there's so many different flavors of dokey Which one's your
favorite?
oh fuck okay anyway so yes I started my day at 10 in the
morning because almost every day I have to attend an
interview regarding our new manager slash talent manager
position because our staff team we have hired everybody for
a staff team except for manager the other staff positions
were pretty easy to fill um because we sort of have like a
vision of what we want but a main manager slash talent
manager is quite difficult because uh you know we want
somebody that like we want to make sure we don't you know
fuck up because like it's a lot of responsibility and it's
like there's a lot of work going into uh going into like the
main manager slash talent manager position so we somebody
that's perfect because I didn't have to attend any of the
interviews for the other positions um and it was a very like
uh well okay we didn't really we didn't have interviews for
the other staff positions the manager positions where we do
have interviews because this was very important for the
events and the product management is very like clean cut on
like what we wanted and like the resumes we received and
like we like we we want we there was like we had like and
because of that it was very easy to hire for the positions
for those positions um but the main manager talent manager
is where it gets a little harder it'll get not a little very
hard because we don't want to mess up in that area because
they have a lot of power obviously i'm the main power
i want this talent manager to be able to do things so that i
don't have to be involved in behind the scenes work and
stuff so i can just say yes or no to things because I'm like
the final decision because it's me anyway um so like almost
every day for the past week or so starting on like you know
last Monday I think last Sunday I've been having to wake up
at like 10 30 uh 10 30 a.m um almost or 10 a.m depending on
like if I woke up at 10 a.m I'll just I'll just keep at I'll
just be like okay I'll just stay up till the interview
because all our interviews me and so like i had to you know
i have to uh go and sit on the interviews and stuff just to
be like if i like the person or not because they'll have to
be like like i don't like you know it'll be awkward to the
interview this person and then and then you know they hire
them and then i hear them for the first time and i get like
a weird vibe it'll be like oh i don't know like after they I
have to be there for her.
Because I always trust my gut on things.
Like, my gut hasn't really failed me so far regarding, like,
who to trust, regarding, like, people to hang out with, who
I trust.
I always trust my gut, like, my gut feeling on people.
And so, like, that's why I have to be there in the
interview.
And, like, I don't talk.
I mute myself.
I just listen in.
I'm, like, an observer.
And we have somebody that does the interview for us.
So like every almost every day since last week I had to wake
up so early.
I'm not used to it I'm not used to it at all And we had a
whole month of this to go Because we have to do a second
interview After the first interview Because we're doing
first interview Then we're cutting the pool in like We're
cutting the pool in like more than half obviously and then
we're gonna do a second interview and then if they pass the
second then second interview is when i actually make my
decision but we're still in the first step we're still in
the first interview step at the moment um and obviously
after the interviews we have to um we have to like uh go
through our notes being like what we felt like me and the
interviewer be like okay how do we have a feeling about this
and everything um and uh and all that oh my gosh you're so
so much work so yeah that's what i was today i was in a
staff meeting uh regarding talking about the interview we
just because like it's an hour too the interview lasts an
hour uh so like after the interview's done we have to do
notes and stuff and then then it was like 12 15 and i was
like fuck because we have to release the store because i
wanted to i had you know we were we planned Before my
stream.
So then I was like, oh my gosh.
Anyway, the shift our meeting.
Because we have like our other staff members are in the
meeting as well.
So like I was like, all right, time to shift the meeting to
the store.
And then we were talking about the store.
And then we had to make sure everything is good to go.
We know that one of the Twitch analytics is broken on the
store.
But that's not on our end.
That's on the analytics website.
So we had to...
We had to like, we had to like go and get that ready So
that's why I was late
Oh my god, I have to go to meetings again, guys But this
time, I'm the boss But yeah, anyway, I saw some people were
like What about Mr. Men?
I talked about it before, but Mr. Men is taking step back um
they are not working on uh as the main manager anymore
they're working on like getting contractual work so like
basically bringing in sponsors bringing in like contracts
and stuff so we're moving on to like as an agent type deal
because agents work on sponsors and they take commissions
off of the sponsors that they bring in um so because of that
we are in a transition period at the moment um so mr man is
working on being more so outside duties um and and uh and mr
man is has always been working on this as a side because mr
man has like another job like a main job i've always i've
been like a side gig type deal um because uh mr man this
says this if you don't know mr man um actually has a main
job and i was taking on the side to help me get started type
deal because you know I fucking started Doki Bird like so
I'm not started Doki Bird return to Doki Bird I returned to
Doki Bird with basically like zero prep like you know I
barely had time to really prep for all of this so Mr. Matt
helped with getting making sure like you know going in and
now now that like you know um we've had like we're trying to
build the structure now and mr man doesn't have a lot of
time to really like dedicate fully to this so we're looking
to it so that's why he decided it was time to step back um
it was his decision to step back and we agreed that like um
um he'll be working more so on outside outside rather than
instead of like inside uh i want to say inside the company
but it meant more so like in like you know what i mean um
and so he's so that's why we're hiring a main uh a main
manager a main talent manager to to work on this like full
time type deal um and and so because of that That's why
we've been hiring and stuff And So we need somebody who can
commit more time To Doki Bird To me and being able to
Because I also have to do a lot behind the scenes stuff
Right now and we're trying to Avoid that like So I can focus
More so on streaming And I really I just really want to do
Is focus on streaming and my creative My creative ventures
like my projects And stuff like that and so we need to hire
somebody that's can handle more behind the scenes um so like
to the point where i just need to say yes or no to things
like i don't really want to you know i don't really want to
do behind the scenes stuff i don't really like not i want to
say i don't like doing behind the scenes stuff but like i'm
i'm tired i think i think that's uh that's like the best way
to describe it uh i am i'm tired and i just i just want a
street so that's why that's why that's what that's my goal
that's honestly my goal
uh let's see because like every day every day um i basically
before stream and after stream I just work like I I don't
have really have time to play video games nowadays like off
stream the only times I do get to play video games is when
I'm streaming um because every day I'm always like working
on something regarding um regarding like within the the
we'll just call it the company I don't know what else to
call it and I'm like working on something within the company
and like trying to like I am a workaholic but like the
workaholic sometimes like as a workaholic I take most
enjoyment in like working on my channel in terms of like
stream content and like projects I don't mean like the
behind the scenes logistics of stuff is where I don't
consider the workaholic part like The workaholic part
doesn't really include much about like the paperwork and the
behind the scenes and the logistics of everything.
That's not where my workaholic tendency goes into.
But sadly I have to work on these things almost every day.
So when I say I've been very busy, I've been very busy.
so that's basically where it's at at the moment yay um oh
anyway what else what else do i have to give updates on um
but yeah like i know like we're growing a lot too our team
is our team is growing a lot at the moment and i don't know
if it'll be something that we can have forever if i'll have
this big of a forever because I don't know what next year is
gonna be like this year um this year will is like it's been
very good to me I think as long as now that we have the
store out I'll say that a lot of the salary has been helped
by you know you guys of course like you guys are supporting
me but like um now that we have our official store out and
we got a distributor going in we can finally and if by we
start launching more products more regularly that most of
the salary um i think like majority of the salary can be
paid off with our merch sales and which is great i really
want to say thank you again guys like it's crazy how much
merch can like like it's crazy like i said um if i had
regular merch sales the merch sales could account for like
60 to 70% of my salary of like a my income type deal like
like because merchandising is like like you know how like uh
like has been hotel pop was it the poppy circus whatever
like that shit like merchandising really fucking can make a
lot of money for stuff and they're they're right It does.
It's actually crazy how much you can actually make out of
just merchandising.
but yes, the store doesn't really have anything new.
The only thing new is the Kuroki Voice Pack.
Plus, I think we only have the Doki Makura.
It's only
we really only have the Doki Makura stock still in because I
think, like, apparently I ordered too much of the Dookie
McCurdy.
So we have, we have, like, we have, like, sort of, like, a
little bit of an excess of it.
So that's why, like, we can ship it right away because we
have too much of, I might, I might have ordered a little bit
too much.
So, so those can be instantly shipped out.
um no thank you for the super chat thank you thank you
genuine question are you no longer a thief are you
concerning overhauling the dokeyverse lore given how what do
you mean the dokeyverse is the dokeyverse the multiverse is
the multiverse um like i said it is a skin suit like i can
take my skin suit off at any times each skin suit so you
know how like some people have like multiple passports with
like multiple identities so that's me all we know as long as
in the inside it's the tomato because like that's my true
form so i could be like what do i feel like today do i want
to be a thief today also i feel like a lot of people forget
that i'm a thief here because i'm not very stealthy
so so you know if i'm on the run i could easily just take
off my skin suit and put on a different skin suit.
So like, it's like having multiple passports.
So I have multiple passports.
Like, it's not identity fraud.
If it's my identity, guys, that's not what it means.
That's not what it means, chat.
That's not identity theft.
It's my identity.
Let's see.
Then, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
After that train simulator stream, I do not want a flavor at
Tokey.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Also, like, okay, it's really funny.
One of my friends actually told me about this.
But, like, I need you guys.
Like, you guys really want lore of the tomato.
The tomato, my true form.
uh was made i was born out of spite
only the bark knights uh only the bark knights will remember
this uh
like the bark knights will remember this moment this stream
i never revealed my true form until one stream where it was
revealed and created out of fear spite and it blew it blew
up so much i don't remember the full i honestly don't
remember the full thing of how it happened because like one
of my friends brought it up um because we're talking about
croaky and then we're like oh yeah i can't believe croaky
like became such a big part of you already like after you're
released and then and then one of my friends was like yeah
like just like just like your true forum your true tomato
forum that was like a joke slash spite and I don't remember
I think it was something we're guiding like um I I think
like I was like someone talked about how much they fucking
hated tomatoes and then i started watching tomato videos on
stream and then i was like that's me and then i was just
like oh my god guys that's me and then i think like i pissed
somebody off i don't remember i like i pissed someone off
because i kept talking about tomatoes and stuff and then
they got really mad about it and i was just like that's me
i'm a tomato And then, and then like, and then like, uh, a
couple months later, I think, and I just revealed it.
I was like, hey guys, so I had this, so I've actually been a
tomato all this time.
I've had this, uh, tomato form lying around for like a
couple of months now.
I just, I just didn't know, I just didn't know what to do
with it.
And then I think I brought it out on the Apex stream.
Was it an A-no, yeah, yeah, I brought it out.
It just out of nowhere.
I was just like hey guys anyway, here's my real forum
Yeah, I just like and then everybody was like what the what
the fuck like Like it's just like wait you had this you had
this forum laying around for like like a couple of months
and you just suddenly brought it yeah I just casually just
brought it up I just didn't know what to do same with the
croaky I had I had it for a while I just didn't know when I
could bring it up because it was I don't know I just thought
it was a funny idea and I sometimes I like I like commission
things or like I order things in advance I don't know what
to do with it I just think it's really funny, but like I
don't really have an idea I don't I It's just that I don't
have the idea I just thought it's funny and then like later
on I'll just be like anyway
Here it is I'll think of some of you like I'll be like well
I have the reveal but like I don't know how to fuck to
Segway to it, but at least I have it
Let's see, Devlin, thank you for the super chat, thank you,
thank you, thank you, uh, but yeah, that's how, okay,
similar to Kroki, all right, okay, guys, before we talk
about Kroki more, let me show you guys other stuff, guys,
look, we, we, I feel like everybody forgot that I also
debuted a Chibi model,
I, everybody sort of forgot about the Chibi model, that also
debuted guys I don't know if you know this but we have also
had more than just one debut chat we have also have other
models too such as the chibi model so I'm gonna tell you
guys the behind the scenes so the chibi model we went
through a lot of drafts for it like I told you guys went
through like a couple of drafts regarding the chibi model so
this is what it originally like the first rough drawing like
i said it's from preachy and we work with preachy before and
it was long so i made some edits to it and in the end it
yeah it was like it was pretty long i was like i don't know
i feel like i have like a fucking uh a six foot tall brain
inside this four foot tall
young man And then later on like this is where the edits got
to we edited all the way to this So it looks a lot better
now now.
It's not as long.
Yeah, it looks like I'm mega man So again We edited it all
the way to this.
This was like the rough sketch.
Oh, and then some of you guys might recognize this
peak of the uh of the chibi model a long time ago because
some guys might remember the screenshot in the member stream
so that was actually came from the chibi model
yes the screenshot of i actually posted a little screenshot
a crop screenshot of the eye as like a sneak peek in members
but like all it was so funny because everybody thought it
was the youtube's figure when the youtube's figure came up
um people were like oh my god you were previewing the
youtube's figure in your members but jokes on you guys it
was actually the chibi model
that was actually the preview i posted in the members
channel uh give me this mega man flush all right thank you
for the super chat gamma thank you thank you so yes it was
that was the original that was the first preview i gave um
that people were like huh and we had actually had like
different um uh styles going in we were like playing around
with different eyes so this was the original concept uh what
the eyes originally looked like um i'll show you guys um
this is actually what the original the original eyes looked
like i was not sorry wait all right you're um i wasn't
really feeling the eyes in particular because i felt like it
just felt a little bit off so like i asked so we were going
through like so many different like eye designs because like
i i'm i'm a huge perfectionist uh when it comes to these
things so we were going through like a lot of like like
being like oh i want to fix the eyes like this is the only
issue uh that i had there so we were like going through
different eyes and stuff so this is another eye concept we
had where we removed the bottom of it and then we had this
version where it's like black pupils and everything and then
i didn't really i like i was like what do i look like with
black pupils and i was like oh god i look like i'm staring
into your fucking soul so so i was like oh maybe maybe not
Because I look like I'm staring into your fucking soul right
now with those black eyes.
So then we were like, okay, why do we do like something like
this?
Not the black eyes, but like with the pupils being a dark
green.
And then we finally settled with.
We finally, after all of that, we settled with what we have
here.
this is what we sell the order because I thought it looked
the best but then it wasn't over I was like no we gotta
remove the bottom part the bottom part doesn't look that
great and so in the end boom that was the eye style we went
with uh you see all these it's just small little changes can
affect a model so much um because like I felt like you know
like you can see from this it really changed like how oh
wait sorry it really changed how it looked in general from
from the what like the little eyeliner in the bottom can
turn into something you know just changed how it looked in
general so so that's like I'm such a like I said I'm like a
huge perfectionist when it comes to this I'm like a huge
like stickler for for details and um and you know i want
some uh i want something that looks like you know appealing
um so um this is where we ended off on um and it gives off
such a different vibe it makes it a lot cuter so it went
from so original all the way to the end let me show you the
original again um it's crazy how far the design process was
for this it was a lot back and forth i really appreciate
preachy for like um for willing to you know um what's the
word for willing to like uh go through with the back and
forth and the attention to detail and everything So it went
from, let me save this real fast.
Sorry, my English today is extra fucked up.
My brain is like still booting up at the moment.
So my brain today is extra slow.
So this is the original.
Oh my gosh.
From the original, which was super long to this.
So yeah, a lot changed.
oh my god yeah a lot definitely change to get to where we're
at from big brain to to something that truly reflects my
bird brain um yeah it's actually crazy while i was working
on the new uh while i was working on the new skin suit um
when i was like talking to uh our uh you know What's the
word?
So we have a skin suit designer and then what would you call
somebody that makes a skin suit move?
Like I guess like the skin suit tech.
Okay, and then the skin suit tech guy
The skin the puppeteer the skin suit the the skin suit
engineer.
Yes, the engineer.
So I was talking talking to the skin suit engineer, uh, so
that they are, they can help build the skin suit up so the
tomato form can easily go into it.
So the skin suit engineer, um, I was talking to her and I
was like being giving like critiques and stuff being like,
yeah, we should swap this.
And then she was like, wow, like I didn't even notice that
you have like, like, like really close, like, like good,
like eye on things when it comes to attention to detail and
stuff like that.
So like, I'm a huge perfectionist, like I said.
So, I really want things to look good.
So that was the before and after to how we got there.
Oh, yeah, you should see, like, my edit.
Like, I would, like, actually edit the, like, the work in
progresses that were sent to me.
So, like, this is, like, what I sent.
I'll show you guys what, like, I sent back to her for the
3D.
So this is, like, what I sent back to her.
oh I don't know it feels like too long so and then I would
send it this back to back to her too I'll send this back to
preachy on like how how I think is because I thought the
arms were too long as well so I edited the arms and I made
like the body like a little bit shorter because I thought
the body was too long too so I like squished up various
parts and proportionate and everything and um so it was like
more so a back-and-forth to get to where we're at and then I
think I did like another back-and-forth too so then after
they edit it I would be like okay I want to edit again and
then we would do another edit and then where it gets closer
and closer to like the original to like what we have today
um ginger thank you for the super chat thank you thank you
um anyone else not buying into Obviously, she has a pit in
the basement where she keeps her victim.
I don't know what you're talking about.
I don't know what you're talking about, man.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
So, yeah.
So, it was a lot of, like, back and forth and stuff.
And finally, the plushie design was actually so easy.
Because we sort of, like, had a since we already have the
you know we had like the model done the plushy design was
very like intuitive on what we really wanted and i'll show
you guys so at first we just went like we were thinking like
oh just smile but then i was like no open mouth i really
wanted to be open mouth so then we went from this to uh to
this and i was like no teeth we need teeth because i don't
want like mushy baby mouth you know where like it's weird
there's no teeth there it's just weird so then we added
teeth because i don't know i just thought it was weird that
it was like fucking like like some fucking baby with no
teeth you know
so so we went from this to this and that was like Basically
how the final form looks like in the end.
And it was very easy.
It was just like small changes.
It was just the math and everything.
In the end, it looked like this.
In the end, we had this.
So yeah.
Like I said, I don't like having really long delays when it
comes to merch.
Because the one of the biggest issues I have with that.
Like in the future, there will be pre-orders.
But I'm going to try and minimize the pre-order dates.
Because the worst part about like pre-ordering stuff as a
consumer Is the very long wait and then like, you know,
people move A lot of people move and it's also a huge deal
to handle on the distributor side Because they have to like
handle on where people are going to be moving And changing
the addresses And some people canceling orders and stuff
like that Or like they forget they ordered something like
this And then or like it's just too much know manufacturing
delays happen like right now i have the lunar new year stuff
there is a manufacturer delay with the lunar new year stuff
because we had a little error in production um and because
of that um i'm not planning on opening pre-orders for this
until the majority of the process is done and more so and
then like we can put pre-orders for it later um we can order
like you know we have like a set amount ordered and then
we'll pre-order and if there's extra if there's excess then
we'll have we'll order more in another time um but yeah so
um it's a bitch um and it's it's actually like such a bitch
to deal with when it comes to like uh changing of addresses
and everything and also well not like a bitch to deal with
but like more so like it's a lot of work to deal with
because when there's a pre-order going in.
And we...
Because, like, you know, one or two person chaining of
address.
Very easy to handle.
Like, you guys make a note of it in the order sheet.
But when we have a lot of people, like, you know, like, you
know, people have lives.
I don't know if you know this, but I think you guys are not
bots, and there's actually, like, real people watching me.
And you real people have lives outside of me.
So...
so I assume you guys will have you know you guys will have
to move or you guys will be doing other stuff you know so I
know like somebody would say like oh but we're youtuber fans
so we know how long it takes sometimes guys please respect
yourself more
Like, like, it's like, okay, so it's more so of like, I want
people to be, like, I don't want that to be like a norm, you
know?
Like, I don't want that to be, like, a norm for my store,
because, uh, like, somebody's like, I have merch I waited
over a year for it.
Yeah, but I feel like, I feel like that shouldn't be, like,
the norm.
in things like i understand for um uh for things like
figures and stuff like that like that i understand because
figures obviously they take like uh they like manufacturing
costs for figures it's a lot and you know they're hand
painted and everything um i feel like small things like this
uh because i've waited i've waited a year plus for figures
and stuff which i understand because figures is like much
more there's more like manufacturing into it uh and uh and
stuff like that so i understand because a lot of them are
like hand painted and everything so to deal with the order
process but i feel like smaller things like this um i'm
willing i don't want to have like long pre-order times
because they are like smaller and like um and and you know i
don't want you guys to have buyer regret after like half a
year i'm waiting like you waited half a year and you're just
like why did i order this
it's like yeah don't we have buyers so I'd rather have like
shorter pre-order time or like in a way or like I don't I or
in a way where like you you don't have to wait too long to
receive your product um but because we're still you know
like right now that's why I'm not opening new orders for
stuff because I want to make sure um I want to make sure
that um oh yeah yeah by Sonia yeah easier to make easier to
make like I understand and stuff like that but i feel like
these things like you know like acrylic stands fucking
plushies okay plushies does take a lot but it's also
plushies taking a lot is also due to the fact of the process
of making it into a real product like a real full-size
product and stuff um and and i want to make sure that you
know it is like this looks this is gonna look like what i
see Like, this can look good in a 3D4.
Like, like shit like that.
Like, I want to be sure that I will be able to actually
produce this before I make you guys.
I don't want you guys to pre-order a PNG.
And then, so, you know, like, and it looks like a fucking
bootleg.
You know, like, there's like, like, okay, you know, like
there's like Nendroid plushies where there's like a bootleg
version of the Nendroid plushie.
at the you look like oh that like the png of it and then
like yeah the png pre-order and then when it goes into like
the actual plushie it looks like it's like and then you
bought like a bootleg version and stuff and it's just not
what you think it looks like okay let's see bootleg nendroid
plushie oh my gosh the knockoff shit is oh no like oh i
think the best example okay yeah
This is such a good example.
Wait, I need to show you guys.
Okay.
Wait, this is actually such a funny example.
All right.
I don't want it.
I don't want it to look.
Oh, my God.
What the fuck?
I've been looking at the knockoff.
So, so like this is, I don't want my plushie to look like
the one on the right, guys.
I don't want it.
I want my plushie to look like the same quality as the
other.
I don't want it to look like the one on the right.
Oh my god, wait, I can I'll show you guys Um, okay, so like
one of my some of my friends are making plushies and stuff.
Wait.
Oh, it's so funny Wait, I need I need to show you guys.
Okay, so my friend my two of my friends, uh, actually they
Recommend me the plushie manufacturer and it's so funny.
Oh my god.
Okay, wait, I need to show you guys the
it's so good as in like it's so bad so my friend is making
um uh wait i need to wait actually does she like also if i
suddenly if my stream suddenly stops working i need you guys
to know um it's because the power's out
i forgot there's like power maintenance and stuff so if my
power if I was an internet it's one or the other it's either
internet or power I can't remember I think it's internet so
like if I suddenly stopped streaming the internet cut off so
I posted I so that's why I just disappeared yeah I heard
that the chat is really weird though I'm gonna see I
actually I don't know if I should show it yet because I
don't know if she like ever announce these plushies so i
gotta make sure i gotta make sure that i'm not accidentally
leaking anything because i remember asking like oh yeah can
i show and she's like yeah like but i don't remember if she
ever like showed these plushies yet to you guys like for
like pre-order and stuff i don't i don't remember so i'm
making sure i don't accidentally leak this out
No, I'm making sure I'm researching.
I'm researching right now.
Wait, let's see if my other friends online first.
Oh, wait.
Shit.
Okay.
I'll ask her.
I'm messaging.
Okay.
I'm trying to remember not to read the message out loud
Alright Let's see Alright we won't show it until we get
approval Because I don't remember I don't remember that's
the issue I actually Okay I don't think I've seen her tweet
about it before Wait has she God damn it I don't know guys I
don't know if she ever tweeted it out I'm not leaking deep
night.
I'm a good person.
I'm checking her Twitter right now to see if she ever posted
pictures of it.
If she didn't post pictures of it, I'll wait until I get
like a reply back.
But it's so, oh my gosh, I wish I, it's so fucking funny.
Like that's all I can say.
Because like you go from prototype to the finalized version.
I just want to say that.
To that one guy that's still waiting for Sandland We're
gonna get there We'll get there soon You had four other
Sandland Don't worry We'll get there soon All the people
here Now waiting for Sandland We'll get there soon I
couldn't make the behind the scenes it's own thing guys
there was just there was like too many days okay i don't
have enough content to make it its own stream chat so we had
to we had to do it here okay we had sad lad needed sad lad
had like four other streams it's okay with sharing it's it's
okay with sharing a bit of its stream time with oh i got
approval okay guys okay i'll show you guys it's so funny so
they're like uh so more calliope plushies uh and and they
were sending me because like i asked him for like advice on
um plushie manufacturers and this was like this was the
first prototype that they received so this one's from pokey
uh pokey pocums and oh my god it's so fucking funny
Every time...
This is the...
I'm sorry, this is the very first...
Um...
Prototype.
That was like, uh...
Sent to her.
And I was like, why is it...
Why does it have like a fucking trash bag?
Because they were trying to get the pattern.
The...
A pattern down.
So...
So like, she was already...
So this is like the illustration.
This was the illustration.
And this was...
This was the...
First prototype.
That's what I mean!
It's very hard to prototype plushies!
So...
So this was like the very...
The illustration they sent.
And then they received that.
So then, you know...
My friend was like, um...
No.
No!
So they...
They had to do like edits and stuff.
Like, you know, uh, they had to do edits and be like, yeah,
can we like, you know, fix all of that and then fix the, um,
the drafting of everything.
So they're just waiting on the second.
I don't, I don't think I was sent the second prototype
because they were, you know, yeah, now it looks like
closing.
But it went from potato sack to, yeah.
I'm sorry it's so funny it's so it's so the potato sack is
so funny it's actually oh my god it's so good I love looking
at it anyway um my friend uh uh Gigi she is a big Zeno Zeno
blade fan so this was their pro it's not as like big as a
transition as it was the the Cali one because like So this
was like the first prototype And then This is what it looks
like Afterwards which was a huge Improvement IMO But This
was the second The final So the transition between These two
worked Like more seamlessly Than You know Than the Cali one
Ha ha ha ha To be fair, the left one's naked, too, so it
looks scarier, because it's like, you know, when things are
naked, you're just like, why is it naked, you know?
Like, yeah,
so, um, so, yeah, so, I mean, the left, left one's naked,
but then, you know, the, the, you know, so now the right one
has clothes, so it looks less threatening.
uh so it's less yeah the right one looks more friendly now
the left one is like yeah i'm naked we're gonna do about it
uh uh yeah so so that's an that's what i mean when i meant
like my when i when i say like plushy prototyping is very
difficult work because um because you know from the first
prototype to the end and majority of the pre-production
majority of like the oh sorry you're right we need like
naked bars on it give me a sec all right is this making you
guys uncomfortable give me a sec i i know a way to solve
this all right let's see uh let me let me see i can do this
all right uh and then opacity is Oh, wait, no.
It is background opacity.
There we go.
So we can cover their identity.
All right, so like I said, the one on the left is a
criminal.
So much better.
Is that better, guys?
Will we ever get a tomato plush?
Yes, in the future.
One day, one day you'll get a tomato.
I'm plushy.
Steven, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Oh, thank you for the super chat.
When are you doing the Sandland donation, Donatathon, where
you play Sandland for two months straight?
We're already at like one month of Sandland.
I did not expect Sandland to go this, to go this far.
So, I mean, we're nearing two months, to be fair.
We're already nearing two months for Sandland.
But thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
One more month to go, guys.
One more month.
Yes, check out Gigi and Pokey.
I love them.
They're really great friends.
Oh, and they were the ones that suggested the flushing
manufacturer to me.
So when I get the prototype, prototype one, don't worry
guys.
I'll make sure to show you guys what it could have been.
You know, what?
I'll make sure to show you guys What the plushie could have
What you could have got If we had a shorter production
Um But yes Anyway what else Oh yes Crokey Uh Crokey Alright
Let me grab Let me grab the Crokey stuff Real quick Uh Let
me I didn't prep any of this to be fair i just went straight
into all right let me grab this stuff real quick oh my god
there's so many messages guys okay i did not realize i have
all right i need to reply to some emails after the stream i
did not see this i did not see this um um all right i
remember to reply to this.
No, it's not my business email.
It's my other email that I use to contact people for
commissions and stuff.
So I separate those two.
I separate like my, because like I'm contacting people for
commissions myself personally.
So I separate my business email with that.
And I didn't realize when I woke up, I didn't realize that
that I had emails I replied in a day.
Um, I feel like Kroki, Kroki was sort of really easy in
terms of, like, to get finalized.
I did ask for, like, uh, variations on stuff, because I
really want to see what it looks like.
So, Kroki could have, like, I wanted to see if Kroki, um,
was just, was just, like, one full flat color.
So, like, there was no, like, extra, uh, things to it.
let me see if i can i think it's this one no that's naked
guy here we go so croaky could have looked like this where
it was just uh the wings was it's not its own color but i
felt like it blended in too much with the rest of the body
so i was like no so let me see and then yeah and then after
that i was like no i wanted i don't want croaky to to have
you know to have like you know the wings being like I think
like croaky originally also the body was darker as well and
I didn't like that too so we changed so that and then so we
change it to having the wings darker and oh my gosh where is
the first croaky where the fuck did the first croaky go
oh yeah wait okay there it is okay So yeah, Crokey could
have looked like, where's the other one?
No, that's not, oh yeah, Crokey could have looked like extra
dark, and I was like, oh yeah, no.
No, because the color balancing, like, you could barely see
my expression and everything.
So like, I was like, oh my gosh, it's a little bit, it's
like Crokey is, it was like, it was too night mode, you
know?
the the hat just did not translate very well with with a
darker version of croaky this is like what is it called like
the eviler eviler croaky so yeah croaky croaky also went
through a lot like not a lot but like a few minor changes
and emo croaky like that's cro you know it's like Sonic, and
this is Shadow Kroki.
Yeah, the worst timeline, Kroki.
You ever change?
I didn't like the color changes of the beak as well.
It felt like the beak being the same color as the body felt
like it represented the best out of all of them.
But yes, there is, this is Shadow Kroki.
a gun it would be perfect uh croaky the croaky the crow
shadow croaky and croaky and shadow croaky and croaky we
just need to give shadow croaky a gun and then everything
will be perfect uh not so deadpoint thank you for the super
chat thank you thank you all girl croaky um but yes that was
basically the croaky process now new skin suit new skin suit
all right i said i'll give like i'm Honestly, I talked about
it in the community post, but yes, I'm scared.
I'm nervous.
I'm scared.
I've been, like, I've been, like, anxious about the new skin
suit for, like, a couple of months now.
It is a gamble.
It is a big gamble because, like, you guys know, my current
skin suit, it is four years old.
Like, it can now walk and talk.
I mean, yeah.
it can you know it can go to kindergarten now and like this
is the skin suit that everybody like knows me by like now
and like it's you know everybody sees this and they're like
that's dokey and yeah that's me but i i like it's still like
a past of me as well and if i had a choice to like you know
come back with a newer skin suit I would have done it but I
couldn't because one day one day is not enough when it comes
to prepping a new skin suit so that's why I was I'm really
scared because like I said a lot of guys are very used to
what I look like now and um but I felt like I changed a lot
as a person as a tomato I changed a lot and grew a lot as a
content creator and I felt like I really wanted to um have
something that basically merges all my experience together
and also uh feels more like me And, um, the thing is, being
a thief is all about stealth.
Well, I think we know by now that I'm not a very stealthy
person.
So I could be the worst thief imaginable.
I'm technically the worst thief imaginable when it comes to
stealth.
Mandy, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Doki with a revolver and in the O West and has her birthday
on July 4th.
still trying to fight the being an American allegations.
Thank you for the super chat Betty.
Thank you.
I bet you guys didn't even know Shroud's Canadian.
You guys just assume everybody's American.
I bet you guys didn't even know Shroud's fucking Canadian.
He could have been the most American person there but you
guys didn't know.
He's actually Canadian.
Oh my gosh.
Did you know the actor who plays Homelander?
I thought of the actor who plays Homelander.
I knew he had like an accent, but I always thought he was
British.
But then I found out the actor of Homelander is actually New
Zealand.
I was like, oh my god.
Well, I know Tens is Canadian.
I knew that because like, uh, like, uh, I used to watch Tens
a long time ago.
So I knew like that he was Canadian.
He's Canadian.
Um, I actually found out.
Trout's Canadian from like uh from like my short that talked
about Trout and somebody my chat somebody commented is like
oh he's also Canadian I was like what the fuck he's he's 30
and he's Canadian oh my god but yeah Anthony Star the guy
who plays homelander in the boys he's actually from New
Zealand he's a fucking Kiwi I didn't know that I thought he
was British I thought he was like because like a lot of like
um a lot of people play like american characters usually
they come from i mean to be fair yeah usually they come from
like uh the uk uh when they try to do like american stuff
like you know the guy who plays house god what's his name um
they have really good american accents though a really good
american accent is actually crazy how good their american
accents are um kaz thank you for the super chat thank you
thank you don't worry dokey are didn't hurt too much either
you'll be fine thank you for the super chat thank you thank
you fox thank you the super chat thing thank you just by the
silhouette it really brings back memories and it's gonna be
so you us dragons well dory try not to worry ducky thank you
thank you for the super chat fox thank you thank you thank
you nethy thank you for the super chat thank you thank you
honestly i don't mind the first facial expression because it
looks as if you're judging us also satellite guys we're
gonna get the satellite soon i know i said that like 30
minutes ago We're almost there, okay?
We're almost to the Sad Lab.
Alright.
Thank you for the Super Chat.
Thank you.
Uh, Usni, it's okay, Doki.
Oswala is also a cowboy cosplayer, and he's not American
either.
Think of it, Super Chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Cosmic, thank you, the Super Chat.
No matter if it's a new skin suit, we will still adore you,
Doki, of who you are.
Thank you for the Super Chat.
Thank you, thank you.
I really appreciate it.
Um, we're not even in Sandland anymore.
We're in fucking Forestland.
We're not even Nielsen!
Anyway, as I was saying, as I was saying, regarding the new
skin suit, like I said, I am wearing, obviously, it is a big
change.
Some of you guys were, like, giving examples of, like, oh,
but they do that, too.
But, like, they still kept, like, main characteristics of,
like, I guess, like, they kept main, key main
characteristics from, like, each suit to make the...
like so that the transition is easier um the new skin suit
there might be a big change when it comes to certain parts
um it's also like i said it is a new skin suit creator so um
uh claya is not the claya has had input as well regarding uh
design concepts and stuff so um so like she had it too she
helped with some of the parts like trying to figure out what
i wanted for like her and my new creator both like worked
together when it came to like figuring out exactly what i
wanted we went through a lot of concepts we went through a
lot of drafts to like pinpoint exactly like okay i'm
satisfied with this but i am worried i am scared because
like i said it is a big change and And, like, it definitely
will not look like this when it comes to, like, the style
and everything.
It's a new brand.
And, obviously, it is a gamble.
It is a big gamble because changing brands doesn't work all
the time.
So, so, so I'm scared.
because change is very scary we all are scared of change so
i really do hope you do end up growing to like it if you're
like weirded out by the new look that you'll still grow to
like it because no matter what in the inside it's still a
tomato so like it's just this just has a new skin suit a
different profession so so that's all I hope for so yeah
that's really all I really want to say about the new skin
suit um I worked really hard with uh preparing for it the
team that's preparing the stuff for uh for uh uh for
saturday so like um i hope you guys will enjoy what i'm
cooking on saturday you know when i say like um this project
is going to be my biggest one yet i think this project well
i want to say like downer like the vichat worlds did take a
lot of fucking work when it came to like the team itself and
um the team the team handling itself and me looking in but I
feel like since this this is the most people I've ever hired
when it came to working on a project I think that's the best
thing I can say regarding on what Saturday is gonna be
Saturday might be like the most people I've ever fucking
hired to work on it
So, I hope you guys will enjoy Saturday.
I really do.
Also, because of that, because of how close my new Skinsuit
reveal is when it comes to my birthday, we're going to,
you're going to realize that Saturday might as well be sort
of like similar to what a birthday...
project might be and because it was so close to each other
the birthday might not be as cool we might i i'm gonna let
you guys know i'm treating i'm treating saturday as my
birthday project so
so so like because of that You can tell.
My birthday will basically be pretty lackluster when it
comes to the Saturday.
Because I couldn't do two big projects in a row.
Yeah, skin day over birthday.
So I hope that's okay.
Because I know people were like, oh boy.
She's going to plan so much on this day.
Oh my god.
And then her birthday is going to be like.
two two weeks oh my god what a what a oh my god that means
her birthday is gonna be also amazing i just want to please
lower your expectations on the birthday because i spent all
my effort garring people for for for skin suit day
next scene thank you for the super chat thank you thank you
as long as feels like you're on the inside that's what's
more important you'll still be a little tomato no matter
what as long as i am still your little tomato that's all i
care about that's that's all i want all right finally after
an hour 15 minutes it's sandland time okay wait jk jk
because i need to boot up sandland give me a guys give me a
sec just gotta boot oh wait gotta plug in my controller too
give me a sec i'll plug in my controller all right all right
and then oh no my cables are tangled up so i gotta untangle
my cables give me a sec guys i'm untangling my cables and
then and then it's sandland time then this gameplay time the
10 of you guys here that's for sandland uh that's it oh my
god holy okay i think my favorite part of all this is the
moment i was like yeah it's sideland time i like 50 people
left instantly okay that's it i'm not gonna lie that's
really funny like not gonna lie that's pretty funny i'm that
they're weak don't keep their fucking wings scatter let's go
guys the people that actually cared about sideland let's
fucking go okay give me a sec i need a uh they don't
understand peak exactly they don't understand peak gameplay
now some people are like well i wasn't even gonna stay for
saturday but now that you called me out i'm gonna stay here
out of spite to prove you wrong um um no but they give the
super chat thank you thank you guys they hate trees and they
hate sand too all right let's see they aren't properly
addicted to the tokyo i'm thinking of the super chat coyote
thank you thank you uh all right let's see where's my solo
there you go all right and then we gotta swap to uh where's
sandland there you go sandland yay all right we're in forest
land now for those of you who are watching sandland for the
first time we're in forest land yes it was clickbait we're
actually in the forest right now your comrades are living it
up you're not joining the man and welcome to the tomato farm
welcome welcome not so dead poor thank you for the super
chat thank you thank you sandland filters out the weak
dragoons from the insane what thank you for the wait then
what do we not have normal dragons yeah do you intend to
keep that from them forever no i'll tell them oh she's not
gonna tell them she's half demon why not get it over with
now sometimes you gotta wait for the right time prince tell
them you're half demon more it'll eat away at you if you're
going to tell them better sooner than later Maybe you have a
point.
Yeah, they might as well know now.
I mean, they might be racist against demons.
But, like, uh...
But you're half a demon.
And you're, like, one of the three women in the camp.
Alright.
It'll be a bit awkward, though.
They end up burning her for a witch.
Everyone.
Listen up.
Half demon.
No wonder she is so hot.
I'm calling you out, the dragon.
There's something I have to share with all of you.
Burn her!
Why is she stiff all of a sudden?
You can tell us that- She's a witch!
Or she's half a demon!
Burn her!
Right.
Well, I'm not actually fully human.
As it turns out, I'm half fiend.
Huh?
Is this some kind of joke?
I'm being serious.
I had no idea either until recently When their mom looked
different My mother Like Like when the mom Look like a
fucking demon There's no demon there that looks human Cause
they'll be like Why are ears pointy Mom like
JP they give a super chat Thank you thank you The weak shall
fear the sad true can't believe it well
queen lilith was a fiend all along heatherling thank you for
the super chat thank you thank you your very first super
chat too thank i knew i knew sandland we have real sandland
dragoons here i knew it was the one who was lying to us
turns out the only liar was you long ago oh no but like a
fiend protected them a fiend saved their lives this is a
serious matter it could threaten the very existence of the
resistance i apologize wouldn't us wouldn't us fiend teaming
up with them already threaten the resistance to share a
secret king jam and queen lilith wanted kept so badly like
we already teamed up with literally the prince of the demons
daughter he
really was being my control Oh, she's a succubus.
The only truth and what Bred said is that Lilith was in fact
a fiend.
King Jam was not being mind controlled nor manipulated in
any fashion.
The two of them were truly deeply in love.
Damn, it must be wild.
That must have been wild for King Jam.
was still awfully convenient for your cause wasn't it jam is
a real one that i cannot deny what the heck i can't tell
what's real and what's a lie anymore finally the forest
satin land nerdy thank you for the super chat thank you
thank you i honestly don't know who or what to believe at
this point that's easy the only person you can fully believe
in is yourself are you telling me now you think and's your
enemy just because she's half being man that's some straight
up prejudice there
i need some time to go good idea maybe we should revisit
this tomorrow morning we have another similar conversation
guys what does this change She's just half fiend.
Like that changes nothing.
Anne, I'm so sorry for causing you such distress.
Oh, I'll survive.
It was just a bit of a shock.
Now I've kind of warmed up to the idea of being part fiend.
Finding out I've got an uncle was a plus too.
Okay, but like, okay, what I was so confused is that, like,
she could always talk to animals or bugs.
Like, did she not tell anybody that?
And be like, hey, that bug just said hi to us.
Like, did everyone just thought she was crazy?
Aren't you bothered by your allies turning...
There's, like, one thing I don't really...
Like, there's always, like, such big plot holes when it
comes to, like, anime in general.
Oh, it comes to any story, not just anime.
One of the biggest plot holes that I've been, like, thinking
about a lot was the fact that, like, for those who ever
watched Dr. Stone, started off in the village that village
is full of inbreeding from six people it started out with
six people and that village grew to 50s villagers i kept
thinking about it i was like did they inbred to this like
because the village started with six and then it grew to 50
people and i i've been thinking about it the past week guys
i've been thinking about i literally was thinking about it
past week and like i was like googling it because i i i yeah
let's sleep i was just like how did this happen and i was
like googling i was like is it inbreeding and everybody on
google was just like yeah most likely and i'm like why did
they not explain this
i was just like why didn't they explain this i didn't know
I didn't know it was like they actually came from six
people.
I'm going to keep fighting for the resistance.
Yay.
Are you sure?
I'm a scout.
It's my job to go see the truth for myself with my own eyes.
They don't, though.
Their only health issue is, what was it, pneumonia?
Like, pneumonia and fucking some little child who needs
glasses.
That's the only defects they have.
Long ago, I'd have left after hearing this.
But now I know that some demons can actually be trusted.
I vote we keep on resisting too.
Is no one?
Oh, shit.
This guy's extra racist.
but i guess oh never mind
never mind he's not how about you false alarm he's not what
are you talking about i can't even imagine leaving princess
and so they're not racist they're just sheep they believe
whatever the fuck they want to believe they believe whatever
the fuck the main person believes they're all sheep they
don't think for themselves before then they were super
racist against demons but now that they're okay now that
this guy's okay with it they're like you know what i just
like being in a group i it's like i just like being in the
group right now i don't want to leave love to i want to be
included we don't know where he's being
follow whatever the main person believes in we're just a
stump on our objective of reclaiming the aquarium the
aquarium we can help with that we saw the rough location of
the capsules with the radar at end mill base wow you
actually know where it all is no we have the tracker the map
please right This story would have been more interesting.
There was one guy that left and joined the enemy team.
They were transported at high speed.
There's still one left that Brad hasn't gotten his hands on
yet.
All right, which one is it?
Rionda Battleship.
A sunken ship known for giving even famous junkers trouble.
But then if we had that happen, the scheme would be like 50
hours long instead of 30.
That's no reason not to go.
indeed we leave as soon as everyone's ready well we're
traveling light so we might as well go on ahead yay oh we
finished the quest yay yeah we never finished oh my god
she's finally in my party it only took like four parts
You're finally useful?
Just because we replaced you?
Oh my god!
You finally matter in my game.
She's real.
Oh my god, this took fucking forever.
Holy shit.
It took us fucking forever to make her matter in this game.
Oh shit, okay.
Can I actually jump off?
thank god oh my god she was relevant again she could have
helped me like 80 years ago but that's okay all right
ancient gold coin i don't need treasure maps any rare items
you find all right not sure true but i remember hearing that
some groups of people evolved the genetic traits that
reduced the effects of inbreeding clock thank you the super
chat thank you thank you there were six people it doesn't
matter if it reduces the traits of inbreeding It was six
people that started the village.
And that's assuming they made two kids per couple.
All right.
Let's see.
Oh, can I bring out mock?
Okay, I can't call a ride yet.
It's just...
That's why I was so confused.
Like, I didn't think about it.
And then I was like reading up Dr. Stone Lord.
And then, like, they were talking about, you know, how this
village, there's only one village in the entirety of Japan
for that lore.
So I was just like, okay.
Because I was like, did anybody else, like, unpetrified
themselves before then?
And they're like, no, just these six astronauts.
You know, just six of them.
So now I was like, wait, so that entire village came from
just six of these people?
And then people in the chat.
And I was reading the wiki and, like, the like the
discussion they're like yeah inherently results in a
different ecosystem
so i got so i don't i don't know i've been guys for entire
week i've been thinking about the dr stone issue the dr
stone inbreeding issue it's been i've been it's been like my
head for an entire week now because it's i because it
doesn't make sense like this this thing is all about okay
okay one of my biggest issues with dr stone is that dr stone
is all about science and like scientific discovery ocean
from the edge of forest but if it's all it's about science
then why the do we have an inbreeding problem
why why is there why are they not solving the issue it's
about science the entire ball goodbye the entire present
premise is science
so like what oh my god i keep going it's not it is how can
there be a village of 50 people and the biggest issue they
have is that somebody needs glasses like they don't have any
like third like they don't have like you know like the
egyptian problem with egyptian royalty and how you know what
was it king tut has so many health issues and that wasn't
even 3 000 years that was like at best six hunt 500 years
king todd had a fucked up back um like elongated head or
some shit and like uh and like bad jaw she had so many
health issues but like the best the worst that happened to
that fucking village of 50 was that one girl needed fucking
glasses it doesn't make sense
Like, if it was any other, any other manga or, like, anime,
I'm, like, that's fine.
Like, have that plot hole.
But it's literally about science, and science.
It's literally about science.
So that's, like, the biggest scientific issue I have.
And at least the Pharaoh's infreedom wasn't as bad as, like,
a fucking...
Village of Six?
Anyway, that's all I really want to talk about.
Like, that's...
This is my issues with...
This is my issues with, like, anime plot holes.
Not just anime plot holes, but, like, like, plot holes in
general.
It was worse.
The science is simply not being affected by genetic
inbreeding.
Uh...
You're thinking too much.
No, because Dr. Stone is all about thinking too much because
it's about science They literally went so in deep about
engineering like engineering and like Chemistry and all that
shit, but not on how to make glass and how to make medicine
and like How shit like naval naval Ships work, but what a
But genetics!
It's more about noticing patterns.
Guessing intentions.
Okay, I'm done.
I'm done now.
Well, goodbye.
I'm not okay.
Oh, whoops.
Guys, it didn't work, guys.
No, you have to go all the way back.
Oh, I didn't.
Oh, thank God.
Never punished.
I love not being punished.
okay all right how do i get on get on this yes uh ruse thank
you for the super chat thank you thank you as someone who
took two courses on evolution genetics the inverting issue
is primarily misunderstood by a demon as an absolute sick
people can produce a population of offspring conditionally
thank you for the super chat thank you thank you all right
explain you can't just say it and just be like trust me I
took two courses.
Two courses, I don't think, explains enough.
Source me.
Wait, it's the Omega Raptor.
It's not as good as the Alpha Raptor.
Write a thesis now and argue for it.
Okay, also, like, I don't think two courses can explain why
a fuck six people can make sure inbreeding is good.
not an issue citations needed who is your pre pre-reviewed
source right now get your professor on the line and explain
to me the science of dr. stone inbreeding that's all i want
nice one down 500 words with references now make sure make
sure it has like citations i want the super chat thank you
thank you explain sounds like a lot of science i think we
need an inbreeding arm for dr stone the thing is doctors
they ended dr stone they ended it and i felt like i didn't
get my answers here we go make sure not to go in so deep
that you can't touch the bottom prince Wait, what?
Uh-huh, thanks.
What?
What does that even mean?
I got it, okay.
I know how to keep myself from drowning.
What does that mean, thief?
Why do I have doubts?
They did have a prequel.
That's the thing.
They made a prequel about the astronaut thing.
But it didn't answer anything.
It just implied that the village started off with six!
all right this way we go all right how far is this place
that we have to go i mean to be fair it is a big map it is a
yeah we need somebody to do a case study right now you know
how like youtubers would like recreate
talking we don't need that we never thought we'd end up in a
different country we don't need that we've seen lots of cool
stuff okay but you know how like okay you know how youtubers
oh my god there's cows I knew they were an invasive species
too there's no way cows would survive there's no way cows
could survive in the sand I knew it I knew they came from
here okay so you know like recreate certain things in anime
like the attack on titan that gear and stuff like that and
they'll be like oh this happened in the anime can actually
happen irl
so this is forestlands capital it's impressively vast you
bet this place will keep us entertained for a while
oh this is a nice city oh it's the capital wait oh my god
it's him It's his twin brother!
I think they ran out of models.
Wait, it's him too!
Wait, are they all the same people?
Wait, what the fuck?
Are they part of my crew or are they actually the same
people?
There's no way.
I just found the twin?
Oh my god, what if they actually had another version of
these guys?
Oh my god, they saved again!
This is also...
Alright.
Let's see.
Where do we have to...
Oh, where do we have to go?
Wait, did I went the wrong way?
Oh.
Oh, I was not supposed to...
Oh, I was not supposed to go there.
Oh my god, it's so far.
I'm just gonna...
I'm gonna fast travel to the entrance.
uh it's way too far i'm gonna fast travel to the entrance to
get out out of there i don't want to walk i know i'm too
lazy it's all the way over there oh my god it's so far it's
so fucking far all right here we go i think it's just
because like wait what where where is this where the fuck is
that wait how do i get there oh my god i am so lost i'm so
lost oh there's a road i fucked up with the road hey if we
fall we'll just deal with it okay are you crazy real oh yeah
no okay spoiler for those who are actually keeping up today
okay all right guys okay okay uh for those actually want to
keep up to date with dr stone look i didn't really read the
manga i only watch a bit of bits of the anime and like i
read the whole lauren story of dr stone i just didn't read
the manga itself but i read everything about it about the
chapters and the arcs so like for those who like what are
keeping up with stone dr stone and don't want to get me
spoiled mute for like mute for like what uh 30 seconds and
i'll give you the reason why people turn in the stone okay
now all right the reason why people turn into stone is
because aliens there you go all right now now i after all of
that it was because of aliens
i'm just like after all of that it was it was that all along
just it's oh it's always aliens i
I feel like I feel like whatever they're like what do we do
and then they're like aliens that's like their answer to
everything okay how do we know to unmute okay tell them to
tell them that they can unmute now now they can unmute also
uh Sumi thank you thank you I just had to talk about that
like like i understand if it's like you know you're like oh
you're supposed to have your brain holy shit how far is this
place how far is it the army uses them too so like um i
realize a lot of like anime manga that i thought was like
really smart back then if but like but like reread it?
Okay, I love Death Note.
Don't get me wrong.
Wait, what's this?
Oh, they're snakes.
They were snakes.
All right, I'll let you guys, I'll let the children live.
I'll let you guys live so you guys can be stronger than your
mother.
And then I want you to do a revenge arc and show me how
strong you become.
Anyway, so like, I love Death Note.
Don't get me wrong.
Death Note is a great anime manga.
And I love the series a lot.
I love the author but like when you reread it you're like
wait this is actually for like the fucking smartest for
someone who thinks he's like so fucking smart i think it was
all the premise about being like oh my god he's so i am i am
light i am the smartest man in japan but he's like a fucking
high schooler
he's like he's like a goddamn high schooler and he's like i
am the smartest person in Japan!
And then you run for he's 17.
It's like, I'm going to be a god!
And he's a fucking 17 year old child!
I was obsessed with life.
I remember back there.
I was like, oh my god, he is so smart.
And now I'm like, oh my god, this fucking child.
Fate keeps on bringing us together.
Oh, it's him.
What did I do in a past life to deserve that?
Why are you here?
Do I even need to ask?
Oh yeah, bro, why did it to be normal?
So he pulled out an 18 plus magazine.
Oh yeah.
Yeah, doubt it.
Come on.
Did we really have to do this?
I'm not in the mood to throw fists with you, chumps.
Then take your men and leave.
See, that won't work either.
I got a job to do.
You just can't make some people happy.
Yeah.
Yeah, fight us.
Fight us.
No tanks.
I got a suggestion.
destination no tanks whoever reaches the engine room first
gets the aquarium well i have a bike so you want to race oh
no no wait i'm really bad with races
unless it's garfield cart i'm really good at garfield cart
wait by foot but i have a bike wait for the signal on your
marks wait but if he says it What if he says is that's
cheating?
On your marks.
He's gonna go before before go.
What the fuck?
It's dark.
There's no sun in here.
Oh, he's cheating!
Put your goggles down!
Go!
It's the cool factory.
I can't see a thing.
Oh my god.
Cheater!
Bring out the bike.
It's too late.
He already cheated.
Get the bike!
It's good if I can get the bike now.
Okay.
It doesn't matter.
He cheated first.
It's bike time.
How is he so fast?
He was on foot the entire time.
That's not fair.
How is he so fast?
It's not.
Guys, I think he did more than just use Flashbang, guys.
I think he cheated even more.
Who would have thought the bad guy cheating even more?
All right, we don't need crocodiles here.
They're invasive species.
They came from Flatman.
He cheated on right.
trees jut out over it in a...
I wonder.
You think General Kroa might join us?
What?
I think that might be taking...
Bro, he fucking flashbanging me and you want him to join us?
What's wrong with you, Alan?
Not everybody's a good guy.
Alright.
I know he's hot, but like, come on, Elvis is dead.
Wait, how do we...
How do we get this?
Wait, do I...
Wait, how do I move this?
Did I pick it up?
Oh, I can back grab it!
Okay.
Alright, grab.
Visibility is poor.
You wander around without a plan here.
You're just asking to get lost.
Alright, and then what?
And now push it?
Push!
No!
Which way do I push?
You have to know where you are to get where you're going.
Firmly grasp it.
Yeah, move.
But, yeah.
Yeah, light.
Oh, yeah, this is why I also had an issue at risk.
Thank you, the super chat.
Thank you.
Light being smart went out the window when he self-doxed
himself by murking someone on a talk show only broadcasted
in Japan.
Oh, God, I'm good.
Yeah, because, like, when you...
The anionium's in the engine room above.
When you first read the manga, you're thinking, like, light
is so smart, but the older you get, you realize he was a
stupid fucking child.
Like, with a huge-ass ego.
And then and I'm like, oh my god, I've like encountered
these people before in like content creation Like people who
are too young with too much power
Like it makes sense I was like holy shit everything makes
sense Yeah, it's the it's the point.
I know it was like, oh my god, that's the whole point But
when you're younger you're like oh my when you're younger
you like look up light you're like oh my god he's so smart
and cool like when I was younger reading that I was was was
like oh my god light is so smart but as I got older I was
like oh my god he is a stupid ass child someone please he
has so many issues
somebody slapped this guy he needs to be like he needs to be
slapped right now yes I unironically did.
I thought he was so cool.
I unironically like light as a character.
I mean, I thought L was interesting too.
I thought he was interesting.
But I thought they were both, like, really cool characters.
I was also a huge, okay, confession.
Yeah, you know.
I...
Confession time.
I Don't think I need to say more.
I don't I don't think I need to say more
Wait, what's this?
Yeah, I already said it all.
I already said everything I need to Okay, when you're Oh,
did I hold it?
Okay.
No, no, I don't need to go on.
People who...
People already get the context.
Yeah.
It's open.
I...
Yeah.
I used to...
I was not 18, by the way.
Just so you guys know.
I'll definitely underage
I just need to I want to be transparent with all of you
whoa no backseeks don't you that's still thank you for the
super chat thank you thank you oh yeah no I Yeah, I figured,
you know, since he was older and he was clearly smarter,
yeah, he was, he was, you know, he took the top bunk bed.
No, no, no, thank you for the super chat, thank you, thank
you.
All right, there you go.
That was sort of fun.
All right, yay!
Wait, where do I have to go?
Oh, this way, okay.
Oh, I need to find the box.
Where's the other box?
Where the fuck is the box?
Is that the box?
Where's the box?
How am I supposed to...
Oh, there it is.
Oh, my God.
It's like there's so many boxes.
But where is the real box?
Oh, and I also was a huge NEAR fan.
I loved NEAR so much.
I used to really enjoy...
the character near.
I heard the anime ruin him.
Okay, guys, I didn't...
I only watched the first season of the Defno anime.
I didn't watch the second season because everybody kept
saying the second season was really not good.
So I watched clips of it, but like, I never watched...
I never watched the second season because everybody said
they ruined N.
Sorry.
N as in near.
Yeah.
yeah everybody said that the second season butchered and and
I actually liked the character sorry I called him by his
real name yeah I actually really enjoyed I really enjoyed
that character in the manga but I heard the second season of
the anime really butchered him so i was just like i docked
oh no what are they gonna do write him in the death note oh
no um but yeah i thought he was a cool kid i thought he was
just misunderstood okay he was anti-social as fuck i mean
you would be too if you lived your entire life in the And,
like, all you had was the orphanage.
Uh.
Be fair, elves.
What the fuck is this?
It's just all red crates.
Where is the loot?
Where the fuck is my loot?
Wait a minute.
Where is my loot in this world?
Where is it?
Hello?
loot loot what the fuck is this a maze they gave me a maze
in a dungeon this is bullshit I can't believe it I can't
believe it I can't believe they put me through a maze
where's the yellow paint exactly this blue better be fucking
This loop better be goddamn worth it.
Okay, where is it?
All right, there you are.
Get over here.
Guys, I think I might be a little under level.
Just a little bit, I think.
Okay, nice.
Okay, that might be like overdoing it too.
Just a little bit though.
Only a teensy-weensy on their level.
There's more!
Oh, okay.
This better be the sickest loot ever.
Okay, how do I jump again?
But...
How do I...
Okay.
How do I do the...
Oh, X!
Thank you.
Thank you, game.
Oh, there was loot right here!
No!
up bring me back up okay nice oh my god thank god thank god
there was loot right here okay this better be some sick ass
loot guys i feel like i've been here for a while all right
let's see oh there's more machine gun scrap i need a machine
whoa what are you doing here get out okay tank time tank i
my tank definitely needs it i feel like if i did more of the
side quest maybe maybe my tank would not be as uh would not
be as like scrappy as it is now nah no that can't be it
right nah wait where am i where am i now Where am I?
Do I go here?
Like, like, actually, where am I?
I'm so confused.
Like, where have I gone?
Did I?
Am I going?
Oh, wait.
Is this where I'm supposed to be going?
Here we go.
What?
Oh, wait, I end up going the right...
Oh, it, like, looped back!
Oh!
It looped back!
Wait, that's crazy.
Thank God, I was, like, I was gonna be, like, so lost,
because I didn't know where to actually go.
Okay.
Okay, we're gonna beat up some bombs real fast.
There we go.
Whoa, okay, this guy is so strong, though.
He's so fucking strong, which I appreciate.
Okay.
Okay, we're gonna have to...
No!
I want to open it!
Okay, let's see.
Alright, we're gonna jump up.
Yay!
And then we're gonna jump like a normal person.
I'm gonna get off the machine.
And then...
No!
I'm too slow!
I don't jump high enough!
Wait, I got this.
Here we go.
Okay, what if I cheese this a little?
Okay, nice.
All right, we don't need anything.
Yay, for cheesing!
Hey, if it works, it works.
I don't need a jump bot.
I have legs.
Okay, this way.
This way.
Apago.
Yeah!
uh oh okay that should be a boss fight all right i'm gonna
use the bathroom real quick before we go into a boss fight
i'll be right back guys first bathroom break today
i'm back guys i just remembered this was supposed to be a
race okay that's that's that's actually a little awkward
technically we're racing
Alright, where are they?
Where are these fuckers?
Oh my god, they're like being...
Pussies!
Get down from here!
That's right.
That's what you get for not staying down.
Okay, we definitely need to upgrade the puncher, though.
The puncher guy actually does so much damage.
Get it towards slow and steady, everybody.
Slow and steady.
I just carry this.
Lift.
throw oh there's a throw volume throw mode okay she said me
how to throw okay lift and then boom there you go guys don't
worry this power guys i know this is a battery and like i
should be gentle with it but it's okay it's made of titanium
like a robot chucking 200 meters at it no it will be fine at
200 miles per second don't worry everything will be okay
where is the oh it's over here okay I'll just push it it's
like where's the other one over here too all right yeah it's
made of Aquanium where apparently you can chuck it now nice
what a great puzzle wait water okay I'm gonna punch you get
over here not done with you.
There you go.
Nice.
Happy Father.
Happy belated Father's Day.
Alright.
Nice.
Okay, where's this guy?
Yay!
Wait, there's more?
What did I say?
Get out.
Alright.
I'm gonna get rid of you too.
For what?
It's me all the time.
Robo Smash!
Alright.
Is that it?
Where else do we have to kill?
Where else do we have to... Oh, it's open.
Okay, nice.
That was easy.
Yay!
Damn, that egg has hands.
I like how it's like...
Because like... Oh shit, that's a fucking wall.
Give me a sec.
Give me a sec, little guy!
No!
I'm not tall enough!
Okay, let's get rid of him and get rid of him.
And then we got a...
I need a loot!
Yoki needs loot!
Oh wait, I need to be a big guy to grab that battery pack.
Okay, nice.
Uh...
Oh, I keep pressing the wrong button.
Alright, get over here.
And then...
Ha!
Ha ha ha!
Oh my god.
I think it's so stupid that he chucks the battery that hard.
Because, like, you assume you have to be gentle.
Look at it.
It has, like, electricity warning.
You assume you have to be, like, super gentle.
Where's the other battery, though?
Where would the other battery go?
Yeah, it's heating time.
But where is the other one?
Oh, there it is.
God, they're all just boxes.
This should be yellow.
This box should be yellow 100%.
Get over here.
Kobe.
Yeah.
They're built different.
All right, here we go.
Oh, nice.
Yeah.
No, I'm too big!
no my my achy needs to lose weight you're beautiful achy and
don't let them say that about you all right let's see this
way wait do i have to oh no that's just a crocodile okay get
over here i have double misses okay where do i go oh this
way wait then why is there why why is there like oh it was
this okay i was gonna say like why did it make me go there i
was so confused yay dark energy all right and then wait
there's a door there does that mean loot when there's a door
does that mean loot okay no you're also too big that's not
gonna stop me from getting my loot wait my fucking bike died
that's awkward how the fuck did my bike die how do i get
across from there oh i need to go from the other side okay
wait unless guys i know it's a race guys but like i loot is
more important chat it is a race but then like does a race
give me loot i don't think so it just says you win That's
not loot.
Okay, we have to go here.
We go to the other side.
Loot is always more important.
Yeah, you might win, like, uh...
Yeah, you might get a trophy, but that's not monetary gain.
Goodbye.
It was worth it.
Alright, we gotta go this way.
Oh, it's 2D time.
Is there any enemies in 2D time?
No, okay, there is.
Don't worry, he'll explode before he gets to me.
Timed it perfectly.
Alright, up we go.
Goodbye.
Oh, shit!
Never mind.
Wait, there's another entrance here.
That means there's loot.
It's just a dead end.
Oh my god, it baited me It knows all I want is loot Okay,
this way Assume there's like nothing on the other side,
right?
Oh, that's awkward Oh no, it's all guys, it was strat I died
so I can be on the other side See, it was a strat They
couldn't chase me because I was on the other side You're so
smart dokey Guys, where's my You're so smart dokey, post
Where is it?
Where is my echo chamber?
You're so Oh, Alex!
Oh, you didn't have to say that out of your own free will?
Oh my god, that's so sweet Alex guys why can't you be more
like Alex okay whoa upper punch oh I love it it's aim bot
wait the punches are aim bot it that's great oh my god guys
be more like oh my god out of your own free will to chat you
guys shouldn't have is that great you see this is why we
become streamers wait whoops am i okay oh no i'm not
no i have to redo that okay no i don't wait i have to redo
this oh my god i can't believe it this is not fair this is
not fair have to redo this entire portion?
It's fucked up.
It's this way.
Oh.
Feast drowned.
Alright, we're fine.
Nice.
Alright, and then we grab this again.
It's okay, we're fine.
See, everything is fine.
I can redo this portion.
I ain't scared.
How much HP do you have?
Okay, not enough, but that's okay.
I won't repeat it again.
Nice.
Double hit.
Boop.
Alright.
Nice.
Alright, where's the big boy?
Big boy, get over here.
I'm going to punch you.
No!
Big boy!
Who said you can run away?
Oh!
Oh, okay.
Oh, that's not good.
What if I just...
Oh.
Okay, uh...
Guys, I did not buy anything.
Whoa!
There we go.
Nice.
Oh, okay, that's not a lot of damage, but, like, we'll take
what we can get.
Take...
Okay, we will take what we can get.
Oh, guys.
I might have fucking...
Did not repair anything.
Where are we back?
Oh, we're back.
I didn't even realize my internet died.
Oh, shit.
I didn't even realize that.
Give me a sec.
I'm going to reload my chat, too.
Are we all good?
Okay, here we go.
Are we back?
Here we go.
Oh, nice.
We're back.
Okay, nice.
see nothing bad happen guys the entrance still here elevator
spotted yes we know take it to the floor above
i think if that wasn't youtube youtube's been like
experiencing some weird shit lately it took me like chat was
i think youtube servers are like extra fucked i'm pretty
sure youtube servers are like really bad at the moment yeah
yeah that one that one is a youtube issue i know for sure
because like when i started the stream i had like really
weird like i couldn't start my i couldn't start my stream at
first wait there's like loot there i get there i just jump
here oh shit okay wait i think like is this 2d time oh it is
that's so weird
Wait, where did the 2D get me?
It's gotta get to me first, loser.
Wait, it just took me back here.
And what's the point of this?
What the fuck was the point?
I don't understand.
Wait, what was the point of the line?
What?
This is, like, one of those, like, game design, question
mark.
I'm literally, like, game design?
YouTube is getting more scuffed lately.
I feel like it's just, like, server issues.
Because the thing about, like, YouTube servers is that they
can't really delete videos.
So, like, I'm pretty sure, like, there's, like, people out
there that are...
Oh, that is not good.
uploading as much content as possible just to fuck with
YouTube servers.
Because like, you can't delete content off of YouTube
servers.
It's all about like, they all just, they just, all they can
do is just always expand.
Yeah, all they can do is just keep on expanding and keep on
buying more servers to account for like YouTube videos and
stuff.
So I feel like it's, like it sucks because like they can't
really do anything about it in regards to like the people
wasting youtube space so like i won't be surprised if that's
also an issue yeah all those four hour videos are adding up
all those like no all those videos that like when people
search up like oh i want to watch this movie but on youtube
and it's just like eight hours of like a png being like
please visit our website if you want to access if to watch
this movie illegally and shit like that but like in the end
it's a scam it's just malware
that pisses me off
wouldn't they be able yeah but how would they know they
don't know if it's actually dead accounts or like because
they don't have like i don't think they legally they can do
that
and you're just like bro i thought like they'll have like
you know one out of part remember when people used to upload
part one out of 20 for like random shows or tv shows oh no
i'm about to die all right let's see this this way guys who
said oh whoa okay who said i can't parkour It's not like I
almost died on anything.
I'm pretty sure you can't delete videos off of accounts.
Because, like, you don't really know if they're actually
dead at counts or not.
What if somebody just randomly logs back in and their
account's gone?
That's it.
Then people will get mad.
Because you don't know what the situation is.
Like, what if, like, you know, they were stuck in a cult
for, like, 20 years.
the forest land army like they could be stuck in a cult for
20 years okay nice I drank water they hydrated and like they
just and then like they just got back into access and they
finally left the cult and then they're like man I can't wait
to access my YouTube account that I used to own before I
joined the cult and then it's gotten they deleted it you
don't know that whether like the one thing that was gonna
that like put like you know after going through 20 years of
being in the cult the one thing that was keeping me going
was my youtube account that i still own and i can't wait to
get back to it
oh man that was the one thing every day i just think up my
youtube account and i cannot wait to one day be able to get
back on and now that i left the court
because that would suck that would suck for them wait we
don't how do i okay here we go let's see wait there's like
no way to There's no way.
Oh, there it is.
I was like, where the fuck is the thing?
God, my thing is about to fucking explode.
It's like, it's like one hit.
A fly is gonna land on it.
I'm gonna die.
Man.
Yeah, so like they can't do anything about it.
Whoa!
Okay, we're gonna have to grab the hover car.
We're gonna bring the hover car into this.
fuck i should have been the hover car this entire time but
we don't talk about the the fucking little bullets nice at
least that was sort of fun oh wait there has to be more loot
behind me wait there's more what do you mean there's more
that's the fun he can't aim that's the best part to stand
there all right nice he's dead give me the materials i need
to upgrade no
nice all right that means there could be loot over here
because there's a door here and that's yellow it's yellow
gary thank you for the super chat thank you thank you hey y
'all just got back from watching a movie at my brother's
place.
How's everyone doing?
We're doing great.
We're making progress, I think.
Is there a loot?
Yellow!
I love yellow!
Wait, but where do I go after that?
Where do I do after here?
Oh!
Okay, how do I...
Oh, is it bike time?
It's bike time, right?
That should be.
Here we go.
Okay.
I gotta...
It's bike time.
I just need to, like, get the position correct.
Bike time!
Woo!
Oh, nice.
Wait, that was so cool.
That was, like, some Akira shit right there.
And then, is there more loot back out here?
There has to be.
There's bins here.
Getting all this loot, but Doki doesn't even upgrade.
cookie what's the point you don't even upgrade that's the
principle of things okay all right got to go here you watch
akira no i just know about the slide everybody knows okay
like i understand it's like the reference of all time uh but
it's like i feel like animation companies always do that
reference it's always that reference There's, like, so many
Akira moments, but it's always the motorcycle's life.
Because it's cool.
It's, like, it's like the reference to make, it's like, to
let everybody know that you, I feel like it's like, it's
like the, okay, it's to let everybody know that you watch
anime.
Like, you know, for, like, Western, uh, Western shows, it's
like the calling card to be like, yeah, I watch anime
inserts Akira's line.
It's very cool.
You wouldn't get it, Doki.
I just think it's funny.
It's always...
That's like...
That's like always the Easter egg to let everybody know that
you're an anime watcher.
Let's see.
Is the...
Yeah, it's...
It's like the calling card.
It's like, how would these people know that I also watch
anime?
Yeah, it's like, it's the anime reference.
It's literally the reference to let everybody know.
But wait, what the fuck?
Why did it just gently put it down?
Okay, there we go.
Oh my god.
Is it anime mainstream now?
You think it is, but it's not.
Normies do not.
watch anime still but we have we're getting more we're
infiltrating like i say weird when i barely watch anime as
well i mean i'm out here watching young sheldon i'm part of
the norm i'm part of the problem oh my god i think there's
like this apparently there's this uh there's like uh i don't
know if he's like famous or anything but there's like this
football NFL football player that was like um i love pokemon
like he did like he was at like a pokemon convention or
something and he's like why are you and then he was in an
interview and he was like why and then the interview was
like why are you here and he's just like i like pokemon i
love his response and he's like some nfl player some shit i
think they're neat Is it Jamel Williams?
And then he...
Apparently, NFL has these, like, introductions and shit.
And he made, like, a Naruto intro.
Wait, I need to show you guys.
Wait, okay.
This is, like, very off-topic.
But I have to show you guys.
It's so fucking funny.
Let me upgrade this first.
Let me get stronger.
Wait, let me see if I can find it.
It's so fucking...
It's, like, such a...
It's, like, such a funny video.
Sean, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
supposed to keep dormies out of
my...
Is his name Jamel Williams?
Okay, Naruto.
Is it that one?
Oh, here we go.
Here, here.
It reminds of the Jordan Peel skin.
Oh, my chrome was on, but it's so funny.
That shit is so funny.
I am Like, what is he doing here?
Bro, and then he was at, like, like I said, he was at, like,
some fucking Pokemon convention.
Because an enumerator found him and was like, what are you
doing here?
And he's like, I like Pokemon.
It's always crazy to see.
And then there was, like, this famous singer.
I don't know who it, I don't keep up with, like, pop culture
stuff these days.
But there's apparently a famous, uh, Normie singer, like a
singer that Normie's love, that, like, loves anime and shit.
And she, like, during one of her concerts, she showed
everybody her JJK plushie.
And I was just like, what?
She, like, just pulled up a JJK plushie and was like, look
at this.
Was it Megan the Stallion?
I don't remember.
I just thought it was so funny.
I thought it...
I thought it was so funny that she like pulled like she
brought her brought the plushie to the stage and was like
look at this
was it Megan the stallion wait I need to get to this video I
saw it on Twitter I thought it was so fucking funny like in
the middle of her set she just pulls up JJK all right we
gotta get rid of these guys Pew, pew, pew, pew, pew, pew,
pew, pew.
This is supposed to be a race!
How did he get there so fast?
There's security in here!
How did he not trigger security in?
Oh, the security is on me!
Like, I don't understand!
There's clearly security here!
Why am I the one that has to deal with security?
He was in front of me!
yeah he was literally in front of me he has stealth this is
why i'm going to become a bounty hunter this is why who
cares about stealth when you're a bounty hunter you just pew
pew pew
all right let's see where do i where did i go where's the
door oh there's the door okay let me pull up i need to pull
up that video now i need i don't know if it is her megan uh
stallion j uh jjk plushie was it her wait does it even like
does it even show up does it even okay plushie concert
what's this megan stallion live oh wait i think it is where
does she when does she bring up the
Guys, guys, where do I find the plushy scene?
Okay.
I can't find it.
I give up.
That is, like, my extent.
I looked for five seconds and I give up.
There you go.
There's a...
Yeah, I saw the clip.
I don't know where I...
I think I saw it.
Did I saw it on Twitter?
I don't even know where to look.
Alright.
Up we go.
I'm tired of all the...
Battleship Dungeons.
Oh, thank fucking God we made it.
It hasn't stolen a march on us.
We've got a bad feeling about this.
Let's prepare for the worst before pressing on.
Oh, it was on Reddit.
Oh, hey, there it is.
We're here.
No way!
He beat us to it!
Ow!
It doesn't make sense!
That's right.
I heard you rude meme.
Nobody's faster than me.
Oh my god.
It reminds me that Emperor's New Groove had no script.
Wait, what?
Wait, that's Dragon Ball Z.
It's that guy!
Bro, he got fucking stabbed by a knife and he's okay.
He literally got slashed by a knife by a fucking Mecca.
That was like 50 broken bones right there.
Wait, that's the Dragon Ball robot.
Okay.
idiot forget me it's just a knife
oh shit the blade is really dull you don't understand dokey
yeah i saved your life guys we have a problem as in like all
my robots have like very low HP.
Wait, it's a Dragon Ball Z robot with like cells tail.
Oh my god.
Battleship Defender.
That's what I'm saying!
How come now they fucking fight the fucking other general?
Isn't that...
Bro, it's so fast.
That's right.
I can fly too.
What you gonna do?
Oh, miss.
Okay, that's fine.
It's better if it gets closer to me just because, like, I
can't aim on a tank.
Bro, it's okay.
That's fucking it.
Get in here.
Whoa.
I am not doing any damage.
Get in here, Raul.
I need help.
Raul, I should have upgraded my tank.
That should have upgraded Oh shit Okay Guys I don't Oh my
god Jesus Christ Okay, okay, give me a sec We're gonna
Armour up And then firepower Like this is the only way I
feel like I feel like we No No No!
Okay, I was gonna say it.
This is bullshit.
The moment I have the power up for this, and I miss every
shot.
Woo!
Bro, this guy hits so hard.
What?
Oh, this is very bad.
This is very bad.
Swap bots.
No!
I couldn't swap.
Oh, no.
This cutscene here?
If it heals, I can go for... Guys, it does not heal.
Guys, it does not heal.
heal guy that's awkward
oh no i made this a lot harder
i made this a lot harder than i should have guys guys This
is not good.
I definitely made this a lot harder.
Cooked unless...
Unless...
Okay, we can play this passively.
We can do this.
Guys, there is hope for us.
I can take like two shots.
I can take so many shots.
Guys, whoa, if I just do this we're fine Guys We might not
be as fine as we thought Oh, oh no, oh no
Oh my god oh my god okay oh i have other tears in my
inventory oh thank god okay guys oh my god guys guys it's
okay now that's fucking right i'm back bitch i'm back oh
shit okay it's fine it's fine thank you backseating this is
why I love backseating I love backseating yay okay we got a
heal again okay backseating yay okay don't worry I can guard
oh did she not see that I can Guard!
Yeah!
That's fucking right.
Get over here.
I learned.
Zeon with the clutch!
Woo!
That's fucking right.
What are you gonna do?
Nothing.
Oh shit.
Guys, hey, can you guys like help me out too?
Can't help right now.
What do you mean you can't help?
What do you mean?
Don't worry.
I must get over here.
I can't believe he said he can't help me.
But I can lock on target.
I forgot about that.
There we go.
Okay, don't worry.
Uppercut!
Yeah!
Boom!
Oh, and then the finisher!
Nice.
Guard.
Okay.
We're good.
And then, boost!
And then, uppercut!
cut and then down cut yeah it's a fighting game now let's go
the combo launcher and we're gonna do about it nothing oh oh
shit oh shit oh it's okay i have all the heels rio go in
there shoot your missile that's right kill rio don't kill me
Oh, whoops.
I messed up that, but that's okay.
Oh, that's fine.
Oh.
That's fucking right.
No!
Ryo, you don't get this!
Go for the grave!
Harvest him.
Harvest him and add him to my Mecca collection.
Maybe you can salvage the core frame at least.
Hey, terrain on your parade.
but we don't have much time to spare now i know let's get
the aquarium from the engine room
rb plus a to make when the what how did i get this upgrade
how the fuck the bezel buffs just suddenly learned how to
metallize like that came out of nowhere i just suddenly
received the upgrade i know i was like what What?
It was so nonchalant.
I just received it.
Out of nowhere.
I can't believe it.
I have other items in my inventory.
Holy shit chat.
Is that crazy?
We're the first ones to the engine room.
Which means we win.
I wonder if we'll ever see, though, the sister.
Close the capsule valve, just like Pollock did.
There we go.
Now it shouldn't show up on the Aquanium radar.
All right.
Let's report to Longo.
We've got to tell him there's no more need to come here.
Right.
We did it!
We got the thing!
We did our job!
All right.
No, did she actually...
Wait, is she dead?
How could she be dead?
There's no way.
I feel like if she was dead, like, Beazle buff would be more
sad.
I feel like...
Okay, it's this way.
All right.
Ellie, I feel like wouldn't the king and her...
Yeah, I feel like...
She was...
would like I would know if he she was dead okay we killed
all well I feel like there wasn't there was no demons in
forest land because all the demons were in sand land sand
land is like patient sand land is like the origin of demons
apparently and everybody else were just invasive species
yeah I feel like she has to be so alive okay yeah for that's
that's some forest land propaganda I jump off?
Oh no, I just head downstairs.
I was like, is that just a fucking cliff?
Oh, secret item.
Secret, ta-na.
Fuck the Avatar live action series.
I know that was out of nowhere, but I remember that song,
and Avatar the live action series was fucking shit.
It was just...
It was just... I don't know.
I ranted about it before.
But the Avatar live action.
Like, yeah, the CGI was amazing.
But, like...
The story was like...
The writing was not great.
I'll say it.
If the creators of Avatar, like, left...
There was a...
Like, I can see why.
I can see why they left.
Just...
the story was just i hate what they did to saka like he has
barely any character development now because of like because
they were they like removed they removed his character
development which was fucking weird i thought it was just
weird i think he used a hover bot oh my god my rod is not
doing okay it's okay the cutscene will heal me the cutscene
will heal me guys i'll get to a cutscene there's no more
bosses i'm pretty sure right there can't be any more bosses
general crowa no need i saved your life you owe me now just
came to thank you
that's right now you're my minion that said it's a real
shame I couldn't get my hands on that Aquanium god when you
say Aquanium it just doesn't fit nobody fits the Aquanium
well streets for me i'll follow you there or anywhere don't
worry sir you can make money through other means no bees
above what the are you doing have it you want the what the
the aquarium is used to destroy the world bees above you
idiot
Destroy the world!
And they're okay!
Honestly, I don't even know which way is up anymore.
Later then.
How are they okay with it?
Like, they're just like, alright.
Before delivering this aquarium to Supreme Commander Bread.
Yeah, but why is everyone okay with it?
We'll store it near Crump Army research.
search lab right oh i see but we can't leave it there for
long i see so it's not his fault if the it gets stolen but
how did he know that he would have followed the line now our
official reports can wait let's go see how femans do bro
that was such a huge gamble he could have been like you guy
it sounds like he's giving us a chance to nab it for
ourselves oh really yeah that was such a huge gamble that
man is something else yeah you don't know for sure if he
fucking was gonna let us use it okay we need the water we're
we need water right now oh hey there's this though where the
heck is the water okay where's the water though guys where's
oh there it is okay apparently you can use Maybe, maybe,
maybe I can, like, heal my car.
Can you heal my car?
It's odd that few people seem to live around here.
All right, never mind.
Oh, wait, there's like...
My guess is that most of the terrain is too rugged to build
sizable settlements on.
Wait, there's a...
Whatever towns do exist must be densely populated.
They are.
He'll be surprised how many people live in the capital.
we can use this we can repair it we have oh yeah we
definitely have a lot oh why don't only go a campsite okay
yay all right now for some hard intel on the area all right
there is like a spot over here so i want to see what what
materials it gives that must be like materials and stuff not
so deadpool thank you for the super chat thing thank you the
aquarium could only cause a Warcraft.
That's okay.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Bezo-bub, you are so stupid.
Alright, we unlock that.
Ooh!
More gear.
Okay.
Let's see.
Can I fast travel?
Oh, it's right.
It's literally right here.
Alright.
Fast travel.
Oh, there's a camp, too.
Wait, that's good.
Alright, we gotta rest for the first time.
We're resting.
Oh my god.
For the first time in years, we decided to rest.
I want to see if my car is better.
Yeah, my car is better.
Oh, thank God.
All right.
Motorcycle time.
Wait, another mom showed up?
Not anymore.
Now you're orphans again.
Get adopted by another mom.
I'll make sure you'll always be orphans.
Oh, shit!
Alright, that's awkward.
Guys, I gotta go back.
Guys, it's not karma.
But I need to go back upstairs.
I need to heal my bike again, guys.
Give me a sec.
No, I can't fast travel.
Okay, maybe?
No.
Come on.
Get out!
Get out of here!
Alright, I should be a little fast travel now.
Still not?
Okay, now I should be... Okay, it doesn't matter.
I'm at the camp.
Doesn't matter.
Okay, rest.
There we go.
See, we're okay!
Never punished, guys.
fucking punished and where do we have to go it's this way
it's that oh they're like ores we don't need ores we have so
much of them yay i love not getting punished for my actions
that means i can still keep doing them yay does everybody in
forest land have bots or something let's get rid of Watch
this
It's like punching a kangaroo.
There you go.
That's right.
Oh, you want to join in too?
I'm gonna punch a second tiger.
What the fuck are you guys doing here?
This isn't your fight Just watch you like flies Get over
here Get over here.
You want to fucking go?
You want to fucking go, but punch a bird too
That's fucking right all right now back on the bike back on
the bike cargo but i need to reload all right these guys
don't matter to me go ahead over there
all right up we go and then this way god with all these
mechs why don't i have one that flies that's like the
literally the only thing we're missing i seriously doubt
that bots are expensive to buy and maintain no one talked to
you ral normal people couldn't hope to afford them only the
army it hurt me wait it hurt me
oh my god the game's listening hey crola We came...
Getting right to the point, I see.
That said, it's not like I can just hand this over to you
for free.
So how do we settle this?
How about with that one-on-one...
It becomes self-aware.
Guys, I told you guys, this is why I don't play more than
three parts of a video game.
It starts becoming self-aware.
It gives me the edge.
surely the leader of the demons wouldn't mind such a small
handicap wait what's the hand cap actually the leader of the
demons is lucid fine i'll take you on anywhere there's a
place just west of here a rashia village we're gonna storm a
village right outside town bro they're like let's get
somewhere safe for this right outside a village that all
these all these civilians live you'd better be ready too i
want our duel to be legendary all right oh hey there's more
water okay it's this way like how is that safe we're
literally in another
like I don't understand how that's safe we're like in
somebody else's town how is that safer safe for us not for
them yeah That's all stinky.
I was like, bro, what?
All right.
We'll take that.
And then we'll take that.
And then down we go.
We actually, let's just...
I mean, we could.
Technically, there's loot there, too.
The civilians are just props.
It's like Street Fighter or Tekken where you include the
civilians into the fight.
The environment damage.
We gotta include the environment.
Okay, this way.
Open.
Okay, whoa, that's a big rocket launcher.
I mean, we have so much materials because I don't repair
anything.
Nice.
Okay, so I assume...
Wait, how do we get there?
Holy shit, they're so far!
Wait, how the fuck do I get there?
I wish we do have planes.
I can't believe Rao said we're not rich enough to have a
plane.
I mean, to be fair, he's right, I'm a demon.
Like, we don't have the sense of currency.
But still, it's still not fair.
Alright.
Okay.
I found, no, I don't take fall damage, so...
This stinks
Never Okay, okay, okay, apparently in Sandland you don't
take fall damage Okay, okay, that's actually fucking
bullshit In Sandland you don't take fall damage But
Forestland is different Okay, I guess I have to do this
bullshit shit then let me hug the wall all right now it
should work whoa whoa there we go all right yeah we did it
you fucking did it sorry forestland has its own gravity
apparently apparently forestland It has its own special
gravity That doesn't exist in Sandland Which is great That's
great to know now That's great to know This is what I'm
gonna do Come into the cave That's right, he's too small for
the cave
Okay, get out Get out!
Whoa!
Get out!
out of my team okay nice oh that dodge though that dodge was
fucking sick oh I went the wrong way guys I went the wrong
way very large panther oh my god no not that much these
things move fast elite panther where
oh guys there all right take two it's okay take two i went
the wrong way anyway we were supposed to go this way all
right we were not supposed to go to any shortcuts apparently
uh
okay the shortcut was not needed because there was no need
to take a shortcut Because I went the wrong way.
I want to steal your loot.
Alright, goodbye.
I just wanted to steal your loot.
Alright.
Take two!
Guys, we've only fucked up once.
So this is the second take.
Wait, it's just...
Okay, hover car does like the most damage, what I've
realized.
There you go, see?
And we get snake stuff, too.
Okay, ooh, platinum ore.
Okay.
There we go.
And then, oh, there's more ore.
That's good.
Okay, and then...
More ore.
Oh, it was just iron ore.
We don't need iron ore.
Alright.
And then swap cars.
Bike tab.
Yay!
Guys, we're doing it, guys.
Take two.
There was never a take three.
I don't know why you guys keep saying take three.
Do I save his life?
You know what?
I feel kind today.
Oh, my God.
They were so weak.
They literally are literally just little birds.
All right, give me your shit.
Give me your loot right now.
What do I get?
Nice.
Money.
I didn't do it out of the goodness of my heart.
I did it because I like money.
Let's see.
Go this way, I assume.
Where do I get there?
Oh, this way.
There's a bridge.
Yeah!
And then there's more bridges.
This is such a far village.
Why couldn't we just fight there?
There was like that?
he why Elvis wouldn't just let me fight there no I saw loot
above me I was like oh I don't get up there okay I was like
whoa what's that okay I can walk up there's stairs yeah
there's stairs all right nice Okay.
Here we go.
It's better be worth it.
Crow Romance.
Okay, now I have to read it.
A book that's seen better days found near the village
suspension bridge.
Parts are illegible due to exposure of the elements.
Title Crow Romance, Volume 5.
The novel spins the tale of a prince crow, an impoverished
girl named Afki falling in love.
They made five books of this?
It is pretty good, but the best part's all smudged.
Looks like the letters bled to the ring.
Dang, now I need to know how it ends.
Its owner might be nearby.
Perhaps they'll tell you the ending if you're bringing...
Wait, what?
So, like, is it like an actual bird?
And a...
And a woman?
And a human?
And they made five books of that?
I'm a little confused at the part where like it literally
says crow
So a bird and a woman fall in love Guys you can't just say
it's like princess and the frog because the princess turned
into the frog So it made more sense But this one it's like
full bird crow key was born thank you for the super chat
duck thank you thank you croaky is a full crow
wait oh there he is sorry i was i didn't realize he that was
him i thought that was my crew okay let me second parking
i'm parallel parking right now i won't stay in my bike while
i talk to you
all right
the perfect spot for our contest is up ahead follow me
holy shit he walks so slow so tell me what are you run uh i
don't know you want to handle this one thief let's see where
we've lived on this world long before humanity even existed
think of us as your venerable ancestors Wow.
So you're like the original people of our world?
I knew it!
They were the invasive species this entire time!
They're Christopher Colum- Okay, I shouldn't say it.
You want nothing to do with this annoying conflict they're
forcing on us.
Sorry.
Hey, we're not monsters.
Leave us out of your dumb wars.
Supreme Commander Bread is always telling us that demons are
the baddest of the bad.
I'm starting to think that can't be true Exactly Demons
aren't the bad guys at all I agree They might have the
purest hearts of anyone in this world Our hearts are pure
all right Pure evil Bro can I walk faster Run Run You've
been thinking haven't you about Which side is right and
which is wrong?
It won't even let me stray the path.
Why do I walk to the left?
Nope, it won't let me see that!
I try to walk to the left and the game forces me to walk
straight.
After all this, you really still think bread is in the
right?
You're...
The princess, right?
Under normal circumstances, I'd be at your command.
But these times sure as hell aren't normal.
And I answer only to support you.
supreme commander bread i owe him for taking us in when we
had nothing to our name wait what orphans oh he's an orphan
to turn a blind eye no matter what well to me honor is more
important than being right but this is getting a little
unethical because they took him into the army when they were
little when they had nothing so they're orphans and like you
know All I'm saying...
Wait, there was loot behind me.
I'm going to go back to get the loot.
All I'm saying is that...
Is that...
Is that they've been gaslighted into joining the army.
Is there loot?
I thought they'd be loot!
So, like, he's been in the army.
I'm not saying...
That he might be a child soldier.
All I'm saying is that he said...
He had nowhere to go and he was young.
So, I'm saying that the army might need some explaining to
do about this army.
Right here.
Now then, let's get started.
Yep, you guys just let me handle this.
all right wait what where did this guy oh wait i thought it
was a 1v1 what the what the what the what the what is this
he gets a riding bike and i just get riled in here get round
in here no get over here He has a set.
Oh, my God.
I punched a bike.
That's fucking right.
Get over here.
Get your ass over here.
That's wrong.
Go punch a fucking bike.
Okay, maybe not.
One V, one me, you coward.
Okay, this is bad.
I don't.
Okay.
It's like the bike thing all over again.
It's definitely like the bike thing all over it.
Yeah It's okay.
I'll get there.
I know the pattern I know the pattern guys Guys I know where
he's gonna go I know where he's gonna go guys I swear to
God.
I know where he's gonna go.
No That's a nice speed.
You've got there okay this is awkward this is actually this
is a little awkward guys this is just a look see I knew it
oh shit okay I tank like I tanked a lot of that okay well
maybe maybe punch guy yeah I'm ready wait a 1v1 isn't like
rounds okay guys guys ralph please please ralph yeah i
punched him one time
okay it's fine it's fine i can shoot him too see oh what
does it look like i'm giving up
Does it does it look like I'm giving?
I'm actually trying I don't I don't know why she thinks I'm
giving up I don't know why she thinks I'm giving up guys.
I thought I thought I was trying Okay, we're just gonna No
Really don't throw I'm trying my best Oh, there we go Well,
I got one hit in Guys, look, I got one hit in Guys, I got a
hit A hits, a hit Okay, nice Wait, I'll just chase after it
I have Stop, I'm trying I actually am trying it I know I
know it doesn't look like it, but I'm actually trying.
Please, Adam, try my best!
Okay.
Oh, okay.
There is so many missiles coming in.
No, please!
There's so many missiles!
Okay.
Please We're we're so good guys.
We are so close Guys don't worry.
It's working What do you mean stop?
I'm trying
Tank time tank time maybe it's It's okay.
Tank time.
It's okay.
Oh, it's okay guys.
tank time.
It's okay.
Oh, it's not okay.
It is absolutely not.
Oh, let's get it.
Okay.
Alright.
What I learned is that I was doing the best with the Mecca.
Oh, see?
Kataya!
I told you!
Oh, God.
Oh My god I'm not doing so well.
I'm not doing so well.
This is the hardest fight ever This is actually the hardest
one Oh, please
I'm trying Leave me alone Okay
I'm trying!
There's so many missiles!
Oh my god!
I'm trying my best!
Maybe it's jump bomb time.
Maybe if I just jump, jump all my problems away.
if i just jump from all my problems guys jump oh my god the
jump on okay maybe if i ride my bike maybe i'll just ride my
bike this is it this i guys i figured it out i figured it
out guys i figured it out i can out run this
Yes, I figured it out.
Oh, holy shit!
I have a feeling...
I have... Guys, I don't think I figured it out, guys.
I don't think I...
Guys, I don't think I figured it out.
Don't give up!
It's looking like a...
not figuring it out scenario.
I can't upgrade it, it's Tuesday!
I started the 1v1!
I'm in too deep!
I can't!
I started it, now I have to end it with my life!
Please, Adam, try not to!
I messed up Oh shit
Don't give up Oh my god And it's not by choice It was It was
never by choice Holy shit Do I even have Guys Oh, no, this
is not good.
Wait, I still have one more in there, kid.
Okay, wait, strength.
Temporary brute.
Oh, nice.
Guys, we need to wait.
Where is the firepower?
Okay, we got firepower and we got armor.
This is it.
We go all in, guys.
We go all in.
Get over here.
I'm going to leave.
Please, I have so many upgrades right now, please.
Oh my god.
Does this hit me if I block it?
No, it doesn't.
for mine it does if I couldn't grab I would no no this is
like the most unfair fight ever I swear to God this fight is
actually so unfair please please leave Leave me alone!
Leave me alone!
Fuck it in, princess!
Alright.
Boom!
And then I block.
I can't block.
Oh my god!
Fuck you, Kar!
Holy shit.
Oh my god, I hate this.
I hate this so much.
Bro, this guy doesn't play fair!
Oh, God.
Oh, what do you mean?
I haven't hit him once.
What do you mean, just a little more?
Yes!
Okay, I take those.
But I take those.
I take anything I can get at this point.
Oh god I can't run Guys, I can't run Punch kick No Oh god.
Oh my god.
That's so many missiles.
Oh my god
Okay, okay No, he was so close okay get him oh god oh god i
have to do take the slow and steady take the slow and steady
okay oh no he's doing that thing again he's doing that thing
again oh he's doing that thing oh whoa whoa whoa whoa
punch oh god I'm just gonna poke him oh god not again not
again not again please please do I still do I still armor
nice I do I do oh no I'm overheating oh no this is bad okay
take this take this no no I don't have nitro I don't have
nitro anymore this is good nitro oh no oh no oh god I have
to like Make sure I have enough nitro for this.
Oh, God.
Bro, I'm so stressed out.
No, I overheated.
Oh, no, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa.
Oh, God.
No, oh, God.
Oh, I'm like, yeah.
Do I have anything that has...
Guys.
Guys, this is not looking so good.
Oh my god.
Guys, this is not looking so good anymore.
This is actually...
Oh god.
Oh my god.
No!
Holy shit!
I can't.
Guys, this is really bad.
This is actually really bad.
No!
We were so close!
Oh my god!
Holy shit!
This is actually so bullshit!
Oh my god!
This fucking...
This guy...
Bro, I hate this car.
I actually hate this guy.
Holy shit I think we got the system I think I think we got
it We figured it out We figured it out We figured it out
guys Oh fuck please We figured it out I'll just shoot him
with my gun That's it Boom Okay we figured it out guys We
just gotta believe the missile spam may be a lot How does he
have so many missiles?
Like where is the government mutt?
This is where it's going Oh my god, we did it guys.
We've cracked the code
Oh shit We cracked the code guys Okay, we cracked the code
All right There you go It's like I might need to upgrade my
tank guys Guys who would have thought not upgrading anything
ended up fucking me over guys Can you guys believe it?
Oh god.
You think?
Yeah.
Yeah guys, we might need to upgrade our tank.
We might need to start upgrading.
It's like I'm under leveled as hell right now.
Oh my god.
Yeah, he's ratting me over!
Busted!
It's not fair!
Okay.
I'm trying to...
Yes!
Alright.
You're putting your heart and soul into your back.
I'm trying.
I really am.
Okay.
Jesus Christ!
These missiles are so fucking fast!
Okay.
And I need you to know that I am not I'm not actually
fucking around I am trying my hardest actually the hardest
fight ever It's actually the hardest fight I had to deal
with Okay repair kit All right we're gonna put the repair oh
shit okay never mind all right we still have Okay, we have
armor.
We have firepower.
We have Okay, boom boom.
There you go There you go get over here get over here so I
can shoot you down Oh shit Okay, we just gotta believe Guys,
we just gotta believe guys it's catching fire oh god guys we
just gotta believe guys please please just keep on believing
guys yeah boom oh my god took so much damage from that that
one hit oh no no no no no oh god Oh my god.
All right.
That was sick maneuver, though.
That was a sick maneuver, though.
Okay.
No, I missed!
I took so much damage!
Okay.
Yes, I know.
Bezo buff!
Yes, I know!
I know I'm catching fire!
I don't know what else to do!
Bezo buff, please!
I don't!
Oh no, I've overheated again.
I need a balance.
Okay.
Oh shit!
Oh shit.
Oh please, how many more armors do I have?
Oh no.
Where's my repair kits?
Okay, here you go.
Here you go.
Okay, nice.
Alright, nice, okay.
Oh, holy fuck, that was not worth it.
That was not worth it.
No, they will not do that again.
I will not do that.
Okay, yeah, that hurt a lot.
Alright.
Okay, now.
Nice.
Dodge.
Please do your spinny attack, sir!
Do it!
Okay, nice.
Oh, thank God.
Whoa!
Okay.
Okay, he's doing his spinny attack.
That's good.
That's good for us.
Oh, God, I can't even shoot my gun!
What?
Okay, that's bullshit.
That's bullshit.
Okay, there you go.
At least you know I'm trying my best, sir.
You know I'm trying my best, guys.
After this, I'll level up my tank.
I promise.
I promise, dragons.
I'll level up my tank after this.
I learned my lesson.
Okay.
No.
Nice.
I learned my lesson, everybody.
Never again.
Oh, my god.
Oh.
No, I can't even punch him.
Oh, no.
Okay, nice.
I can't do like a little bit of poke before leave you said
that 30 minutes ago I'm feeling that's not
it doesn't feel like it it doesn't feel like a little bit
more anymore oh god oh god no no I got too cocky it's
because always happens whenever I get a little too cocky
okay here we go I'm slapping it with us there's nothing else
I can do we have to wheedle the damage very slowly
I just have to.
That's all I can do.
The stick play is all I have.
It's literally all I have very slowly.
It's like level 1 versus level 99 right now.
Thief, please.
I feel like I heard that forever, thief.
The more he says it, the less I believe it's a little more.
Oh shit, okay, okay.
We can't punch guys.
We punch.
Okay, we can't get- No!
Oh god.
Oh my god.
Oh, please.
He's so close!
No!
He needs the spin!
Start spinning!
That's the only time I can do any damage!
Okay, but not right now.
Oh god, not right now though, but okay!
Oh god.
I didn't mean now, but that's alright.
I wasn't prepared for the spin.
But that's okay.
God I can see the light as I can see the light it's almost
there I can see the light wait wait is the time I'm gonna do
it I'm gonna do it oh thank God oh my god the aquarium is
yours oh my god oh you sure about that you will definitely
be punished for it's over won't you hey i'll be over back to
being unemployed i guess so what will you do now it's over
off of the aquarium
oh my god it's over I could be special ops a staff officer
Maybe a servant like you Oh are you calling a servant
Because you are You have no other purpose That said I think
there's a princess Who's awful shorthanded on nights Whoa
sliding in that quick Elvis You'll lend us a hand Princess I
don't think that's a good idea I'm borrowing yours Whoa
Okay, that's smooth.
Never mind.
That was smooth, though.
Never have I seen so many Miss House.
Pump, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
This guy's very first super chat, and then they're like,
what the fuck is...
Damn!
That's so smooth.
That probably isn't how you're supposed to do it, but
anyway, my blade's yours.
God, would you...
Get over yourself.
Rose got game.
You said that you owed bread.
Didn't I also say honor is important to me?
Also, bread's not a woman.
So you'll join us?
I got another idea.
Wait, what?
You're not going to join us after all that?
But that was so smooth.
It's a private line between us.
whoa whoa general croa when the time comes whoa yeah he'll
get in touch all right got it i'm off actually sliding into
her dms
we've gained a powerful ally yeah i say don't expect too
much out of him he should just give us that car the bullshit
I just went through I deserve to own that car
what happened we'll explain after you get here bread is
about to make a move even when losing he is winning oh my
god Whoops, sorry.
I don't need a passport.
Alright, let's go back to...
Let's go back to Lango.
Okay, where's the garage?
What's everyone doing here?
Give me a sec.
I need...
This is more important.
Give me a sec.
After everything I went through, give me a sec.
Okay, let's upgrade.
this and then i feel like i should upgrade the battle too
like okay all right um and then after that we gotta upgrade
our parts yeah let's yeah yeah all right let's see oh it's
purple wait okay primary whoa wait that is wait that's
that's a lot is that a lot of damage Okay, that's a lot of
damage.
The cannon?
But, shock split and chance to artillery.
Wait, should we get the...
I'm gonna get the cannon.
It's purple.
And then...
Super...
Guys, wow.
Guys.
Wow.
Who would have thought I was so behind when it came?
Oh my god.
There was a lot of stuff.
needed to do that guys there was a lot of upgrades okay
we're gonna do with a battle armor let's see do we have
anything oh we do okay armored legs yeah i think defense is
good wait we have a cannon too wait a minute that's a lot of
upgrades oh my god all right okay that was uh That was a lot
more than I expected.
That was a lot of bigger upgrades than I expected, guys.
Alright, let's see.
Yeah, I should have gone back to camp.
Is there anything upgraded here?
Holy shit!
Alright.
Okay, there was a lot of stuff I should have been doing.
Should I upgrade everything?
Interceptor, drone, slam into enemies while engulfed in
flames.
Okay, yeah, we need that.
All right.
Okay, we need to upgrade.
We gotta upgrade this guy, too.
Uh, upgrade vehicle.
Okay, I can get it to 60.
Oh my god.
Okay, we don't care about this guy, apparently.
Holy shit.
Wow.
Alright, we need croc alloy.
Alright.
I think our vehicles are pretty.
Oh wait, I can upgrade, like, parts, too.
I forgot about that.
Parts.
Upgrade part.
Never mind.
I need a lot of shit.
How about my this guy?
Okay, I need Cobra, Alloy, Arm Scrap, Crack, or Alloy.
Okay, I need Snakes and...
Alright.
Wait, how do I up get Chip Slots?
Parts?
Make Parts?
Wait, what the fuck?
I can make stuff?
Okay.
Wait, but how do I get...
like, chip slots.
Oh, upgrade vehicle?
Oh, there you go.
Wait, I can't.
It's locked.
I think I need to be a level higher.
I need to be a level higher, I think.
Because I can't get a chip slot.
Because, like, there's no other way to...
Yeah, I need to upgrade uh...
me if I'm gonna do a vehicle upgrade vehicle can I buy it
here yeah I have to oh what level do you have to beat up you
can't even have more than one oh I don't have magnets is it
because I need magnets I need a magnet how the fuck do I
find a magnet do you sell magnets oh hey you got me out of
the items you find do you have magnets Petit Eric, do you
have magnet?
Okay, we gotta buy a repair kit.
No matter what people say.
B-grade shipping.
Okay, armor up.
Armor up repair kit.
Repair kit plus.
Okay, this is where we need to spend our money on.
This is...
Okay, this is definitely what we need to spend our money on.
Okay.
all right there we go all right i don't care if i'm poor now
after all of that i realize what i need to do all right
there you all right now wait workshop maybe you have magnets
you have a magnet
oh there he is oh shit okay wait i can buy so much stuff
okay we need crock alloy and Cobra alloy.
Uh, we can get all that.
And then...
Oh my guys!
I'm...
Guys, I'm upgrading!
Okay.
Alright.
Get back here.
Over here.
Everything I went through.
I realized my mistake, guys.
Okay, this guy...
Okay, croc steel.
Oh, I need a croc steel.
Quality Cobra.
alloy.
My shit's not quality enough?
Wait a minute!
Quality Cobra alloy.
Quality gear.
Raptor alloy.
Scorpion.
Cobra alloy.
Crock.
Oh, there it is.
Wait, what's the difference between?
Oh.
What?
They're saying our desert crocodiles aren't quality enough.
Fucking dead.
forest lander
god damn forest lander they think our crocodiles are not
quality enough how fucking they're there god damn forest
lander they think they're above us they think they're above
the sad landers actually fucked up Good Guys, I'm gonna buy
croc steel too.
God damn it V-grade steel.
There's so many parts I need Typical forest landers.
They think they're so much better than us Okay, we're not
upgrading our fucking bike, I guess Alright No croc eyes No
No Oh, the bike is so sad.
The bike is so sad.
Okay, parts.
Upgrade parts.
Okay, level two.
And then...
Wait.
Oh, I can max it out.
I might as well.
Oh, fuck it.
Well, I mean, Chip's not is like a magnet, so we're fine.
Wait, which one am I using?
Jump bot.
Hopper.
I don't even own a hopper.
Is the hopper better than my jump bot?
Oh well.
We'll not figure that out.
Robotic arm scrap.
Oh I haven't been killing those I guess.
Uh.
Let me calculate that.
Oh I can.
Nice.
Oh hopper is bad.
Okay that's good to know.
Uh I don't have a hover jet.
There's a hover jet.
I mean, I need large launcher scrap.
Okay, I don't have that, though.
I can upgrade this, though.
Okay, nice.
Okay.
Alright, and then vehicle.
Guys, it's crazy.
Upgrading stuff is so crazy now.
Guys, oh my god.
I need more money.
No!
I spent all my money!
Alright.
I think we're upgraded enough for now.
Longo?
Keep watching.
Watch what?
At long last, King Jam has admitted the error of his ways.
Moreover, he has agreed to seed the throne.
To the child?
This is the proof.
How does it look?
Certainly screams royal heirloom, doesn't it?
When King Jam entrusted me with this treasure, I had no
choice but to receive to his wishes.
He stole this from us.
To his will that I replace him as a ruler of forest land and
defend its people.
Bro, what a little brat!
I'm going to fucking hunt this fucker.
It is for us, the people of Forest Land, that Mooniel has
assumed this heavy burden.
From this day forth, we must accept Mooniel as our one true
sovereign.
The coronation shall be held in the palace square
immediately.
This isn't good.
of duty kid sounds like a squeaker now they're stealing my
father's position by force just like they stole the necklace
if we don't counter their narrative they win why not just
use the radio yeah like before if we contact your news
office can they help us reach out to the people directly
Oh my god!
It is propaganda!
They have the media!
They control the media!
But will the people even listen to a plea made through such
violence?
Yeah, and from a fiend to half a fiend.
I'm sure they'll pay attention.
I doubt they'll like hearing you.
Yeah, that's what I'm saying, Udo.
Sorry, princess.
what happened chap on yeah what happened it's not just a
coronation at the same time they're gonna execute no this is
no time for jokes I'm not joking rumors are spreading all
over town there's just no way surely not even bread would go
that far there's no point in speculating waiting portos
infiltrated the army we'll ask him when he returns until
then we sit tight you mean they'll execute my father now now
we don't know that for sure yet let's rest up while we wait
for more information oh no we gotta stop him oh i see like
three different people speak with here oh here everyone oh
we gotta make a choice which one's the most violent choice i
expect muniel will invade sandland as soon as he's been
crowned and if he can you need jam with bread conquering
sandland even those who disapproved of bread's methods will
side with him that is the absolute worst case scenario for
us i didn't want to say this in front of anne but the loss
of her necklace was a problem it's allowed them to make it
look like king jam willingly gave up the okay i think
everybody can see that i don't know everybody sort of knows
that like the necklace was some air there's no way to keep
the king alive anymore
father oh because i lost that necklace why would they want
sandland we have nothing there i wanted to leave sandland
because there was nothing there so is the rumor about the
execution true yeah we have sad at the beach the generals
couldn't stop talking about it they were clearly shaken the
executions supposed to happen before the ceremony long ago
don't worry it's time for the resistance to rescue King Jam
yeah yeah i hate to be a downer but do we even have a
strategy we don't need strategy we have a tank a plan works
well with our numbers it's back to diversion oh yeah guys
we're gonna get a whole bunch of them i.e five people to
reach the palace square and the diversion with the king
being held hostage any drastic moves could put his life at
risk the diversion will come after the to provide the
infiltration team with an escape route ah have you lost your
minds that's it we're gonna leave we supported the
resistance for so long only a total moron would run right
into it yeah just back out now you're in too deep no choice
oh well be my guest just don't expect us to join in No!
Swimmers!
Come back!
No point in trying to force them.
But...
We need you guys to swim!
We don't want to make anyone take part against their will.
Well, I guess I'll sit this one out too.
Wait, what the fuck?
Wait, why can't I just bring my demon army?
Why can't I just bring dad over?
Like, we have a motive and be like, bro, he killed your
child.
Just bring the demon army and get the demon army involved
We've been fighting the good fight for an entire decade now
Let's show bread just how much we've learned about guerrilla
tactics over these past I'm gonna call my dad Yeah Me and
our three people in the resistance Let's go.
We'll work out the details in the field
Yeah, why can't I just fucking call my dad be like dad?
They killed your fucking only Dottie.
Okay.
Where's this?
Alright, nice.
Sadly, our bike is not leveled up.
But it's okay.
Our bike is still fast.
We don't need a level up or bike.
Alright, angle.
I'm ready.
Everything is leveled up now.
Where's everyone else?
They spread out near the capital to cause a diversion.
I was hoping you'd assist as well.
I don't mind, but what about rescuing King Jam?
That's where I come in.
You?
On your own?
That's crazy!
Oh?
I'll show you just how wily this old fox can be.
What's he gonna do?
You always managed to evade me in your rebel army days.
Huh.
That's kind of impressive.
But bread and mooniel are probably waiting at the palace
plaza We'll need more than speed if we want to save the king
any human who could beat Lilith will surely be a match for
the prince, too I still don't buy that she actually lost,
but if she did thief's right.
So I'm gonna go.
Yeah, I'm pretty sure she's still alive There's no way just
how strong this mooniel is when he has like fucking child
how could he beat up my sister my father i know that i'll
rescue him along the way along the way then it's decided
i'll leave the infiltration to you much appreciated we could
reach the plaza using the secret passage under that bridge
there's a secret passage then what are we waiting for let's
go yeah all right this is gonna be easy wait where's the
secret passage okay i'll go to the the capital and then get
over there.
Where's the secret passage?
Is it?
Oh, it's under this bridge.
Okay.
Not too bad.
It should be like here.
Right?
Yeah!
I'm so smart.
Wait, where do I go?
Where the fuck?
This way?
It's been 10 years came through here there's a fucking
village next to the secret passage not so secret i'm not
using it to run away this time huh is that it shh seems
there's still some time before the coronation starts we wait
here until it begins
that's really nice that they're giving like six feet
Holy shit, that's a fucking guillotine.
A scaffold?
Never before has such a glorious day smiled upon forest
land.
And yet so too is it a day of mourning.
That with his cockies.
You guys wait here.
I'm going in alone.
Is being a king like a white collar job?
Like what is this?
Hey, it looks like...
He looks like an old, like an office man.
We'll get caught if we all go.
Just, I just gotta sneak up to Ann's dad.
Grab him and make a break for it, right?
Be careful.
If the guards see you, it's all over.
I know that.
I feel like that's not him.
I don't know.
King Jam was a good ruler.
truth that it takes only a single drop of mud to be foul
even the purest water tempted by a feed king it's okay it's
cutscene stealth that means I don't have to worry guys it's
cutscene stealth guys he must pay for his crimes thank God
for prior to the coronation we shall be holding the
execution of King Jam that's gave my necklace to king to the
child so why are we executing me or executing the king
quick use your metallic power we gotta split fire
this isn't what we agreed on you promise you wouldn't really
shoot i knew it it can't be him i was like why is he just
wearing Cocky's in a fucking business shirt.
It was a trap after all.
I knew something was off.
Here you go.
Something for you to remember me by.
Whoa.
Why, little demon?
Don't touch me.
He reminds me of fucking...
It was like...
I'll tell my father about you.
I won't waste my time fighting you filthy demons again.
What in the world is going on here?
We knew we might be walking into a trap, but not on this
scale.
Is that the forest land army?
The resistance was supposed to distract us.
Where's the resistance?
Who exactly you mean this one you mean the five people three
Wow An army of three
Three old people They're gonna shoot him they're a single
one gonna work Why are they shooting?
What?
Hello?
Don't let him get away!
Now it's four.
Now, this is our chance to escape.
If only they had a weapon!
If only they had a...
Gun of some sort!
Oh my god!
It's only me!
Wait, I can't...
Can't help right now.
What do you mean I can't bring out my tank?
Guys, this is unfair.
I actually have to use my arms.
I can't believe it!
I did all of that and now I have to fight?
I can't lend you a hand right now.
This is fucked up.
Where are they?
Oh, sorry.
Whoops.
I can't believe it.
What's the point?
I spent all my time upgrading my tank and how to use my
arms.
This is bullshit.
This is actually bullshit.
This is so bullshit.
Wow, where did he come from?
Are you serious?
It's a stick!
Why is he raising his hands up as if he's gonna get shot?
Now, Valfine...
Unless you want your friends to lose their heads, get on
your knees and grovel before me!
If I do, will you promise to let them go unharmed?
god what a little bitch this voice actor is really good in
making us hate this character the heck i can't read this
guy's mind either so what'll it be fiend better start
begging before i run out of patience it's a stick why are
you scared
what what the Get it together, Beelzebub.
You aren't allowed to admit defeat to anyone other than us,
the swimmers.
Swimmers, shoot him.
Why did he shoot the floor?
He could have literally shot the Munoil kid right there.
This would have been over.
Swimmers,
you could have shot...
have shot them that's all i'm saying he could literally shot
the menial kid and all of this would have been over okay i
wasn't gonna kill anybody but you were annoying
yeah all right the story would have ended there exactly uh
how is my team doing oh yeah you're gonna cheer me on
instead of running with me okay
Yes, thanks to you.
Sorry to put you to the trouble.
But why?
I thought you wanted no part in this mission.
What plan?
We always have to take precautions against forest land army
spies.
Oh.
So I had the swimmers make a show of falling out with us to
take eyes off our assault team.
Yeah, our assault team of three.
How did this fight...
How did this war last 10 years?
This is a cool question.
Well, they seldom worked on the great general Shiva.
Surely you suspected something was up this time as well.
The possibility did occur to me.
And to the prince.
The fact that this war has lasted 10 years.
Surprised me, guys.
I sure didn't expect it to be this.
That was insane.
We almost died out there.
It was a stick!
Get it out.
But it was a huge success in the end.
Isn't that what matters?
You called this a huge success?
My father turned out to be a fake.
And all we managed to do was run away without getting hurt.
What was the point of all that?
Well, one good thing came out of it.
Wait, what?
What good thing?
Oh, they got the...
The necklace!
My necklace!
They got the air!
Haspick key.
It's a key to a ship or something.
I mean, it's literally key-shaped.
Gramps!
Stop it!
That hurts!
Very nice work, thief.
He did a thing!
Without definitive proof of the king's abdication, the
coronation way to go thief honestly you lot it's a little
too early to celebrate mr.
thief is right we won't have resolved anything until King
Jam is safe and we need to know where he is though where is
he contact trick camp and hurry along the preparations I
tried contacting them but they're not answering wait what's
going on our camp communicators working fine that's strange
that's not good yes sir that does sound odd we'll come to
the camp be fair we brought the entire army a three to this
plan so who's guarding the camp we'll visit forest land
capital and have a look around for ourselves yay i want to
try coconut milk you can son as much as you want how would
they be able to go to the capital since they showed their
faces i assume since they show their faces like they know
what they look like now okay bye god yay oh sorry the team
of four sorry you're right now that there is a team of four
everything will be okay well can i fast travel here that
fast travel here does that work oh yeah it does okay nice
here we go here we go uh this way am i going the right way
yeah i am yeah i still can't believe it i spent all that
time upgrading upgrading my stuff And then they're like, you
got to use your arms.
Like, what the fuck?
Like, vegetation makes for easy ambushes.
I gotta use my arms.
What's the point?
There's like, there's an enemy up every tree in every bush.
Steven, thank you for super chat.
Thank you.
You know what?
Fuck yeah, I need materials.
I need to test my new weapon.
Holy shit, 2000.
Okay.
All right.
Oh, that was strong 2,000 Steven, thank you for the super
chat Thank you, thank you I just got my cherry blush I'm so
happy to have it and want to let you know Thank you for the
super chat, thank you, thank you, Steven I'm so happy it
arrived I'm really happy This way, where is it I think I had
to go up What the fuck was that damage?
That's what we waited for Oh Wait, is it?
Are we supposed to hit the tree kid?
Wait, why do I have...
Oh, I can't fast travel there.
Obstructive view sometimes.
I was like wondering.
Do it with care.
Okay, I almost ran over.
I almost did it.
Yeah, in Sandland, I could.
It's not fair.
You know what?
I need materials.
get over here i need materials right now that's cute boom
oh that's cute that you think you could survive that all
right nice all right oh there might be materials here too
who's in here oh scorpions Okay, this is my level 8 bike
right now.
You can tell it's level 8.
Oh, I already was here.
Do I get anything?
Uh, I get an assassin, scorpion.
Okay, you know what?
I might need that later.
I might need that.
We need to go back to desert land and we want to upgrade our
bike, though.
We don't have...
Wait, there's our bridge here?
Bridge?
Does everybody in forest land have bots or something?
I seriously How do I get over there?
How do I get over there?
Oh, that's how.
Okay, nice.
I didn't realize there was a little area here.
You know what?
Fuck it.
This guy looked at me wrong.
Jesus Christ.
Oh my god.
that is actually overkill expensive to buy and maintain
that's actually overkill oh my god my take is so OP now
we're almost there we're almost back to the tank not tank to
the to the camp
All right, that's awkward.
It's really awkward.
We're just there.
At least it wasn't a game over screen.
General Yippie.
Oh, there he is!
I was like, where's General Yippie?
He's at the top!
If it isn't the fickle matcha with bumbling fiend himself.
I'm a...
May you get hangnailed what the fuck don't worry guys i just
upgraded my tank that's right wait a minute wait a minute
guys wait they're jumping above guys they're jumping over my
that wasn't part of the plan
smart when they jumped over it you're the only one left epi
yeah surrender before you dishonor yourself
further surrender no no it doesn't end like this i'll be
back with 10 times the troops so wait a trembling and fair
gary thank you super chat thank you thank you it's a little
too late get on the bike be also bub he's literally just
running we're in big trouble Bro, wait, but Luto, give me a
sec, I'll, I'll, I'll, I'll, okay, okay, now, he's literally
just running with his two feet.
How is he faster?
How is he 200 meters away from me already?
Somebody stop him.
How, how the fuck was he 200 meters away?
Well, we're surrounded.
An ambush.
He's a very good running.
I've got you good, you foolish fools.
Let's make this the last time.
We have to suffer that stupidity.
Oh, you're gonna regret that.
Bam!
That's right.
And I have another take too.
Boom!
One hit.
Okay, that shield has to be the strongest shield.
of existence that one guy survived a fucking missile like
what the fuck i'm just gonna run you over you know what i'm
angry i'm gonna slowly run you over
wait you're still alive that's fucking right that's right
you see me i'm gonna come up that's fucking right.
Yeah, the shield is stronger than the tank plates.
They should have just made the tanks build off of those
shields.
There is nothing I hate more in the entire world than being
told what to do.
What are you, fucking 12?
Duck, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
I think that might be a war crime joke.
He started it.
I feel like a lot of war is That is like almost like this
that's like a war argument.
He started it
Right there you go Nice.
All right.
Fight time.
Look, it was self-defense.
Constantly going up and down all these hills really takes it
out of you.
Is this a camp or no?
No.
We took a break.
Wait, I gotta destroy these guys.
I'm gonna punch a raptor.
Get over here.
Oh!
Sorry.
I'll leave you.
I'll let you live.
I'll let him live.
There's nowhere left for you to run, half stash.
Yeah, we're gonna go now.
How persistent chasing me this far?
Your mistake.
Oh, great.
Another trap.
How does he still have stuff?
What?
There's nobody here.
He's just gonna walk away.
Bro, he has no more reinforcements!
Oh, shut up!
And bring it so we can beat you down already!
He just walks away.
Where is he going?
What?
He has his own Mecca?
Where did he hide that?
That's fucking right.
This is what my tank is for.
The moment I hit it.
Okay.
This is a little awkward.
Give me a sec.
Oh shit.
Don't.
Oops.
I forgot my HP guys Okay Alright Alright Take one This is
okay This is why I got like 20 repair kits guys It's okay I
spent This is it It's okay we're fine now Now we're okay
It's okay we're okay now Use your boost gun At the right
time to get ahead of him who's jump where am i getting ahead
too oh the sky shot yeah oh but look at that damage though
what look at that damage though oh when i hit the shots
though
look at the damage when the shots actually hit though oh no
oh no oh they're like a lot slower thank god okay at least
they are a lot slower though i appreciate that guys why
didn't you tell me to upgrade sooner
all right well this has to be the easiest fight ever i'm
just gonna stand still
why didn't you listen because i'm a streaming you have to
tell me 80 times until i see it contrary we need him to
spill his guts how's the camp we did it we suffered only
minor damage thanks to all of you stopping epi now then tell
us everything you know about yeah where's king jam and the
forest land armies next move unless you want us to we're
gonna do but please don't be so hasty you don't need me to
tell you that explain
why simply switch on the tv you'll see right away the tv
yeah what does he mean by that
wait what i pledge to devote my entire what and you all in
my power for this great nation of a necklace and you it's
people the oath has been taken they use the mold to make it
we accept king moonio as our one true sovereign curse you
bred so they went ahead with the coronation even after our
attack what i don't quote unquote attack look at what's on
moonio's chest It's my necklace.
It could be a fake.
I doubt it would be that hard for them to get their hands on
a decent forgery.
Look at the square.
You can't see any of the damage from Guppy's attack.
My guess would be that they filmed all this beforehand.
Damn.
That's smart.
Wait, when did this happen?
Or I am the protector of this country.
Are you watching, dear citizens?
There has been a heinous attack on the coronation.
The despicable resistance has joined with Sandland's royal
army.
Yeah, who was recording that?
Those were some good shots.
Who the fuck was recording that?
There was no cameraman.
to invade our realm all to prevent Monio from ascending to
the throne thankfully we managed to foil their evil plot but
this up front will not go unpunished also like why is this
like one screenshot FPS splicing right there brave soldiers
and I managed to band together wait this was pre-recorded
they realized this was gonna happen before the attack was
coming I'm afraid that many of our countrymen gave their
lives in the battle This was an unprovoked attack by
Sandland Yeah, they planned all that they filmed all this in
advance Like even that part I cannot give them the chance to
commit further atrocities For the sake of those lives lost
For our great patriots It is for them That I hereby declare
war They have nothing!
They clearly just got water!
I hate to admit it, but it looks like we've been had.
It's over.
The Forest Land Army is nearing the border as we speak.
What?
We've got to let General Ari know right now.
But we can't contact him unless we go.
back to sandland what are we waiting for i only get to be in
force land for one to stream
i won't let them get hurt i'm sure your father would say the
same thing sad sad land dude no more forest land okay i
literally just i only got to experience forest land for one
stream that is so up what's up fear holy shit how do i get
back to sad land oh my god i'll just fast travel oh this is
ral back to sad land Can I go?
I have urgent news from Forestland.
Can we meet?
If this is about the declaration of war, I'm well aware.
We're busy preparing, so I'm stuck in the royal capital.
Understood.
Then we'll head to the capital ourselves.
Much appreciated.
Until then, over and out.
All right.
I think this is a good time to call it.
I think It's a good time It's a good time to call it We left
forest land And now we're back in sand Land I can't believe
it Guys We did all of that And now we're back to sand It's
like They're back in sand
I only got to experience it for one stream.
How can they do this to me?
I just wanted to enjoy Sandland.
I wanted to enjoy Forest Land.
Cannot escape the sand.
Alright, I wonder if like, okay, I'm going to check real
fast.
Sand Land.
No commentary.
I'm going to check how much we actually have off of
Sandland.
Because I feel like we're almost close to it.
I think we are close to the ending.
Alright.
Where's the sand part?
Wait, we're actually pretty close.
Wait, is this it?
Yeah.
We have...
Technically, four more hours.
Four more hours on...
Are you fucking kidding me?
I played like two hours...
okay don't all right yeah i think next week would be the
last uh next week would be the last section of the the
sandland i'm pretty sure because there's like four more
hours left uh wait actually no 13 14 15 16 4 more hours left
so that's just like i can endurance the next week oh my god
next week would be the last final part of sandland and then
we'll have no more sand This has to be definitely the
longest game.
Well, no, because I played Demon's Souls.
So, like, that was the longest.
Demon's Souls and Bloodborne.
That was the longest games I've ever played.
But, like, yeah.
I mean, it was been fun so far.
And then we had a little fun time talking about, at the
start, talking about, like, life updates and everything.
And, whoa, I'm really tired.
But I always have a great time hanging out with you guys.
dragoons it always is a great time you know to hang out with
you guys and hope you guys enjoyed um hope you guys enjoyed
uh sandland so far next week would be the final part of
sandland uh so we have that left but also uh regarding the
tournament that's on saturday oh yeah i wrote in the
community post for those who don't read the community post
you're like oh my god doki why are you joining a tournament
right before the your new skin suit reveal well it's because
um um rpr invited me to it um and then i said like oh yeah i
didn't say why because i didn't reveal my the skin suit yet
stuff yet so then i told him like oh yeah i i don't know
because 5 p.m is my it's a special stream that i have to do
at 5 p.m so then he was like all right let me ask the
organizer and then the organizer contacted me because i
think like the organizer wanted me as a captain for his he
contacted me about it and then I was just like oh yeah like
RPR like told me yeah I was like RPR told me and um like I'm
gonna be on his team and but I was like yeah um I don't know
if I can do it because like it's on the same day as my skin
suit reveal uh and then so then he was like I'll change the
time of the tournament like is this time better I was like
oh I won't I don't want it like after I don't really want it
after my skin suit reveal because I don't feel rushed your
reveal like it's this time better and then i felt bad
because like he was like i'm changed like he was changing
the time so so i was just like okay i'll join because they
because like they were willing to change the time for it
like two times so so they were like okay so then that's why
i said yes because uh they changed the time of the
tournament for me even though it's literally like Yesterday,
literally yesterday, because I was like, I don't know, I
have to...
They changed it yesterday for me, so I felt like it was so
last minute of a change.
Yeah, they're working around my schedule, so I was like, you
know what, yeah, I can do it as long as, as long as it's
before the reveal, it's fine.
So apparently, we don't know, apparently it's like a new
third-person shooter game with like anime wifus, and the
beta is coming, it's like a beta launch tournament or
something.
So I don't know who else is invited, but RPR told me at the
moment, my team is me, RPR, Shurfor, and Raffle Gator.
We don't know who our fifth is because he's still looking
for a fifth at the moment.
He was like, I'm going to be recruiting a team that's going
to win it all, which I don't know.
I don't know who else is participating.
But like, I mean, Shurfor's playing on it.
And he's like a natural gifted aimer.
So, So, if anything fails, we have short form.
But, yeah, I don't know who our fifth is.
I just found out who our four other players are.
But, yeah, anyway, I have a lot of work to do today.
So, I am going to call here, everybody.
As always, everybody, stay hydrated, posture check.
Get up and move around to get that blood flowing.
And if you stay up for me, head to bed, because you deserve
it.
I'll see you guys next time, everybody.
Bye, guys.
Bye.
Where's my...
Oh, there it is.
Bye.
I was like, where's the screen for...
Where's the scene for this?
Bye for real.
Bye.